hey guys my name is Frank I'm starting a
series on how to program a tile-based
platforming game called rabbit trap it
will feature tile-based collision
detection and response scrolling maps
loading levels sprite animation and
interactive game objects in this first
part of the series I'll be talking about
how to build a strong foundation for the
game the concepts I'm going to explain
are strongly rooted in object-oriented
programming and can be used in any
program to improve organization and
modularity this might seem boring but if
you use this approach it can save you
hours of editing and frustration and
leave you more time to focus on fun
stuff like level design and graphics so
be sure to watch this video
in this video I'm gonna talk about the
model-view-controller approach to
organizing a program and how the
different components of this example
work together in the main j/s file then
I'm gonna talk about how this structure
increases maintainability and modularity
as always feel free to use the comments
section and be sure to check out the
links to the source code and working
example in the video description and if
you learn something give this video a
like
so basically what I have here is just an
example of a model view controller
architecture where you separate out your
game logic from your display logic and
you also separate out your controller
logic so I have my game logic stored in
the game class the display logic in the
display class and the controller logic
in the controller class and each one of
these handles its own business and it's
totally separate from the other so I'm
not gonna run into any issues with
having references to the game logic
inside of the display I'm not gonna have
the controller logic reference inside of
the game I'm gonna have all these
different components interact with each
other through their public methods
inside of the main.js file context and
by the way each one of these classes is
defined in its own individual file you
don't need to have your own individual
files but it makes it a lot easier to
just use these different things in other
applications if I choose to for example
the engine I might want to use this
fixed time step engine inside of another
application at some point so it's nice
to just store it in its own file but
anyway what all this code does for this
example is basically the game class
controls color value right here that's
the color variable from the game class
basically it just increments the
different red green and blue channels
inside of a color value so change these
different colors that you're seeing on
the screen and then it will talk to the
display class which governs things like
the canvas and resizing the canvas when
the screen resizes and rendering and the
game will hand a color value to the
display and the display will render it
on every frame and the engine takes care
of frames as for the controller I didn't
really have anything cool do with the
controller for this example so all it
does is take user input from the
keyboard and tell the user which key he
or she pressed so for example I just
press the a key that's key 65 so
basically what I'm trying to say is I
want to keep things as organized as
possible for this rabbit trap game and I
want you guys to kind of think about
organization of code before you start
developing a game because if you just
jump into things
and try to mesh all this together in one
big file with references going between
different components it's gonna get very
messy very fast and here's an example of
that that I want to show you so I define
all my components I define my engine
it's gonna run at 30 frames per second
and I'm handing in the render and update
function down at the bottom of my main
J's file I'm gonna start my engine and
that's gonna execute the render and
update function 30 times per second
until I stop my game engine so the
render and update functions i define up
here and these are them right here so
the update function is just gonna tell
the game to change that color value and
that's what the update function the game
does just increments this color value in
a random direction gradually to change
the color now the render function is
also gonna be called on every frame of
my game loop and inside I'm actually
going to be communicating the game's
color value to the display and I'm gonna
have the display object draw that color
value to the on screen canvas so here is
a great example of why this is so good
so I could just as easily write object
literals to govern my display logic and
my game logic and you've seen that if
you've you've watched my other tutorials
I'm kind of sloppy I just throw stuff
together with object literals here I'm
not doing that if I had written object
literals I could put a reference to game
color directly inside of the displays
render color function or better yet I
probably wouldn't have even had her
under color function I would just have a
render method that handled rendering the
entire thing the reason I have to here
is because render color draws a color to
a buffer canvas and then display dot
render renders that buffer canvas to the
final on-screen canvas that you see so
the old version of how I wrote my code
or just the sloppy way that I write my
code would just be to put two object
literals on the main J's file and what
would be display one would be game and I
would have a reference to game dot color
inside of my render function and display
would just draw that color directly to
the canvas now the reason this is bad is
because say I want to change the name of
my color variable to hue
if I go ahead and I have a reference to
game dot color inside of my display and
I changed the variable color to hue
inside of my game object now all of a
sudden I'm editing my game class or my
game object to change that value to hue
and I have to go into my display object
and change all the references to game
dot color to game dot hue now that's a
pain I don't want to have to do that and
it's unnecessary so I don't see why I do
it anyway with this method the MVC
approach you don't actually have to have
any internal references to any other
components the display only has
references to itself inside of itself
the game only has references to things
that it controls so how do they
communicate they communicate just like
this they communicate through public
methods so display can only communicate
with other objects like game and
controller through public methods that
it has so if I come into the display
object here and I take a look at render
color you can see that just takes a
color value and inside of it it does
exactly what I said it just changes the
buffers fill style to the specified
color and draws that color to the buffer
canvas and then here's the render
function and all this is gonna do is
draw the buffer canvas to the final
display canvas I'm not gonna get too
much into detail on that but you get
what's going on here now I could have
just as easily gone like this inside of
this function and said game color had I
made these object literals instead of
classes but that's actually really bad
practice because like I said if I change
something inside a game it might break
my display object and prevent it from
working so that's twice the editing that
I'm gonna have to do because I'm gonna
have to change all the values in display
as well as all the values in game so
this is just a much cleaner way of doing
things so basically this is how you want
your different components to interact
and just take a look at this main.js
file it's really short
everything is super clean I just have my
two functions here render and update
that I hand into my game engine
and here I'm defining everything this is
super clean I don't have huge object
literals to take care of just sprawling
out across my my screen here and my
editor and to instantiate everything
it's real simple I just add my event
listeners for the screen resize and the
the keyboard inputs and I just resize my
screen initially so my canvas fits the
screen when I start up and I start my
engine everything runs the way I expect
it to so using the MVC approach or just
separating out the different components
of your game into logical groups is a
really great way to keep your code
maintainable and modular and I'm going
to get into why in the next part of this
video
so now I want to talk about how this
approach makes things more modular and
more easy to maintain so obviously right
off the bat it's a lot more organized
you can see that clearly I have my
different components reference here and
instantiated here in one single line
each rather than having big sprawling
object literals defined and by
separating these things out into their
own classes I have the option of putting
them into their own files which makes
things even more organized because I
could have all of these different
classes right on top of each other in
one big file or I could separate them
like I did into their own files and now
if I want to edit the game logic I only
have to deal with forty two lines of
code apparently instead of having to
search through one big file so that's
obviously one way that this technique
lends itself to easy maintainability
then there's the other thing I mentioned
where you don't have internal references
to one component inside of another
component and like I said then it's a
lot easier to just work with public
methods and have your components
communicate via public methods kind of
like is happening right here in the
render function display is interacting
with game through a public method called
render color rather than having an
internal reference to game color which
would be a lot harder to maintain
because if I change game color in the
game object I'm gonna have to go through
display and edit all of those references
to game doc color so this is another way
it lends itself to maintainability
now what about modularity okay well I've
got a engine class down here which is
basically a fixed time step engine now I
can use this engine in any application
that I want to and it's very easy for me
to do that because this is a totally
self-contained class that I store in its
own file now I don't have to store it in
its own file but by storing it in its
own file I can very easily just
reference that single file in another
application and then all of a sudden BAM
I have a perfectly good game engine for
a whole nother game and I didn't even
have to write code for it I already had
it on hand but if I were to have that
game engine integrated into all
my other components it would be a lot
harder for me to extract the engine
components from say the game logic and
that just isn't very modular the way I
have it set up now is very very modular
and it will save me a lot of time in the
future when I need a game engine object
so sometimes I write my code this way
for most of my tutorials I just throw
stuff together in one file because I
want everything to be there for you guys
to see up front I don't want to have to
bring things in from other applications
but this is how I would go about writing
a more structured application and that's
what I'm trying to do I'm trying to
write this game rabbit trap and I just
want it to be very structured and I want
everything goes smoothly so using the
MVC approach and separating my game
logic from my display logic and my
controller logic is just gonna make
everything go super smooth throughout
this whole process so anyway I hope this
has been a good explanation of how
everything is gonna be for this rabbit
trap thing and I hope you guys are
interested in what's gonna come because
I expect it to be a really cool game
before I wrap things up I want to talk
about my HTML for this example so I
actually am gonna do a whole bunch of
parts in this series and rather than
having to upload the sprite sheet for
this example a thousand times to my
github page or however many parts I have
I don't want to upload this multiple
times my github page because I don't
want to waste memory space so I'm just
gonna use the same graphics I'm going to
use the same HTML file and CSS file and
I'm just going to write new JavaScript
files as me B so that's gonna keep the
memory footprint on my github page a
little bit smaller for this whole series
that I'm doing so anyway the way I'm
going about that is inside of my HTML
I'm dynamically just determining which
JavaScript files to load based on a URL
variable specifying the part number so
when I come into my actual HTML page
here and I look at my URL to the rabbit
trap that HTML file at the end of it
there is a question mark and oh one
which is the part number
for this example now if I wanted to get
the part 2 I would just come in in type
2
I haven't actually made typed or part 2
yet but that's how you would access part
2 so I'm accessing these different parts
with a URL variable that is just the
part and I have a default to where if
you don't specify anything it just
brings you to part 1 so that's what I'm
doing and this big chunk of code in the
minimal the middle of my HTML file is
taking care of that for me so it just it
defines all the sources I'm going to use
and that's just these files here it gets
the URL variable or that part number
from my URL that oh one after the
question mark and then it goes ahead
checks to see if it's a viable part if
there is no part specified it just sets
it to part one and then it just loops
through and adds a script tag for every
single javascript file in the
application so I'm always going to have
controller display engine game main and
manifesto is just my script for the
video and I'm just gonna add a new
script for each one of those and I'm
going to edit I'm gonna parse together
the URL or the source attribute to match
whichever part I'm in so hopefully that
was a good explanation of how I'm
actually getting these things in and if
you had any questions about why my HTML
was weird like this that's the reason
I'm just trying to save memory space on
my github page so being cheap but I kind
of figured out this cool little script
to just import JavaScript files based on
what part I'm in so anyway that is an
explanation of that
this part is going to be on adding a
player object to the screen and
controlling him with the keyboard this
is a vital component of any game so stay
tuned to find out how it's done
in this video I'm gonna talk about the
example program what it does and how the
program has changed since part one then
I'm gonna show you the specific code
that handles creating the player
controlling him and drawing everything
to the screen finally I'm gonna show you
my implementation of a fixed time step
game loop and how it works if you have
any comments or questions post them and
if at any point while you're watching
this video you get the sensation that
you're learning be sure to support this
video with a like first thing I want to
talk about is what this example actually
does and how this program has changed
since part one so all this example does
is allow me to place a square which
represents my player on the screen and
use the keyboard to make him jump up and
down I also added some stuff in for
collision detection and to make it look
nice so he change his color on every
jump and he leaves a trail the reason
he's leaving a trail is just because I'm
filling the background I'm redrawing the
background on every frame of animation
with a slightly transparent background
so that's the reason I'm getting that
trail if I was drawing just a plain OPAC
background or opaque I guess some people
pronounce it that way if I was doing
that you wouldn't be able to see that
trail behind him but I thought that was
pretty cool and it kind of helps you
visualize the what's going on in every
frame of animation because each one of
those squares that you see trailing
behind him is drawn on one frame of
animation
alright so now that you know what the
program does let's talk about what has
changed since part one so in part one I
had to find my three different classes
my controller my display and my game I
also had my engine class and my main j/s
file so all these are updated for part
two that's why the file name has a row
after it the ones from part one like
engine I haven't changed since part one
that has a part one so that's my naming
convention that I'm using really the
only thing that I changed majorly
besides the code that went into making
the example work was I took the event
listeners out of the display and the
controller classes so the key down up
actual event handler function I hand
into the event add event listener method
in my main
jas file I'm actually defining those
inside of my main file now so this would
be one that I moved out the key down-up
event listener and the resize event
listener or actually event handlers
that's what these are so if I come all
the way down to the bottom of my main
J's file you can see them adding these
event listeners to the window object and
I'm just handing in the methods that I
define inside of my main J's file into
these event listeners so that's one of
the changes I made I decided to make
that change because I didn't think that
my event handling system was really
something I wanted to put inside of my
individual classes or my individual
components and the reason for that is a
lot of times inside of these I'm gonna
have to do interactions with multiple
components of my game so for example the
resize component actually needs to
handle two different components and have
them interact it needs the display
component which handles drawing
everything to the screen and all my
graphics and it also takes information
from the game component which has
information about my worlds height and
width and my player location and stuff
like that so that's just a little bit
about the example program and what it
does and a few things that have changed
since the last part of this series
all right so now I'm gonna talk about
how I define the world and the game
object and this is basically gonna
define the world that my little player
square can run around it and jump in and
it's going to find the player itself
that's gonna be just the rectangle that
defines the player as well as the color
and it's gonna handle some collision
detection stuff as you can see I can't
fall through the floor and I can't jump
or walk through the walls so all of this
is gonna be handled inside of my game
logic so I'm gonna come into the game
part 2 file and take a look at my game
class but I'm gonna keep it expanded so
we could actually look at the code all
right so the first thing I'm defining in
here is a object literal called world so
inside of my game class I'm gonna have
access to this world object and inside
of this I'm just gonna have my
background color and by the way this is
that transparent color so if I come in
here and I just change this to something
like zero zero zero zero zero zero
that's gonna be the color for black if I
come in there and save it and then
refresh my screen now I'm no longer
gonna have that trailing graphic behind
my player whenever he jumps but if I
come back in here and change it back
control-z a bunch of times get rid of
that and that and save and come back
here now all of a sudden I get my
trailing graphics behind my player
whenever he jumps in it looks like he
has just a cool trail of fading graphics
behind him so that's pretty cool and
it's really really easy to implement all
you got to do is draw this
semi-transparent background color to
erase your canvas on each frame of
animation so anyway to get back to the
world object I just want to make a side
note of this and how I did that color
trailing feature the world is just gonna
have everything to do with the world so
friction and gravity are going to be
defined here the player is going to be
defined here later on I'm going to
define other objects that are going to
be in-game objects they're going to be
defined here the world boundaries so the
height and width of our level are gonna
be defined here if I were to change this
let's say I want to make the height
something like 200 and have a really
tall screen if I do that and come here
and refresh the screen now you can see
that I have a really really tall game
world and that looks kind of stupid so
we're gonna change it back save refresh
and now I'm back to my normal size but
basically the world object just holds
everything to do with the game world
including stuff like collisions so this
collide object function is just going to
take an object parameter and for now
that's just going to be handled inside
of our game loop on every update and I'm
gonna pass collide object the player
object that we're defining I'm going to
get to that class later and basically
it's just going to test see is the
object to the left of zero so that's
gonna be the far left of our screen and
is he beyond the right side of the
screen is he above the top of the screen
is he below the bottom of the screen
it's just gonna set him to where he
needs to be in handle collision with the
boundaries of our rectangular world here
so pretty simple stuff everything in
this example is actually really basic
take a look at the source code of how to
linked in the description here I have
the update function now this is actually
gonna update everything to do with our
world so the player is gonna have
gravity added to his Y velocity on every
frame this function is gonna be called
on every frame of animation inside of
the game loop the player has his own
update function and if I come down to
the player object down here we could
take a look at it
see what we got here update it just adds
his X&Y velocity to his current X&Y
position go back up see what else we got
here so we're gonna update the player
we're gonna add some gravity to his Y
velocity we're going to add friction or
we're gonna reduce his X&Y velocities by
the amount we defined in friction which
is up here point oh nine it's just a
simple pseudo physics way to employ
friction in your game then we have this
dot collide object this top player and
this is referring to the world object
that we are talking about
so that's a really simple world object
it just governs everything to do with
the world the dimensions the player the
colors that you're seeing in there and
also in our game class we have added or
I've added or Heather the player and
it's a simple class it's using dot
syntax to kind of add this player class
to the game class and that's kind of
just the way to keep things organized
and almost like namespace in there it's
not real name spacing but by doing this
I'm not gonna have a global class called
player instead I'm gonna have to
reference it with game dot player like
that so if I have a bunch of classes
that I'm throwing into an external
context say your game is gonna run on
another website and it's gonna be part
of the global scope of that website you
don't want your classes and stuff to be
just floating around with all the other
variable names and class names that
other developers have defined so it's
good to try to abstract out your own
class names and variable names and do
stuff like put them into anonymous
functions just to keep your code
separated from everybody else's code out
there on different websites but anyway
that's besides the point we define our
player class here he has a color he has
a height he has a width
he has X&Y velocities he has a value for
jumping to determine whether or not he's
jumping and he's in the air if he's
standing on the ground we also have his
X&Y position and since I'm just being
lazy and I'm not loading him in from a
level map I'm just gonna define his
values all right at the start here when
the player object is instantiated
instantiated with the new operator so
now I go into the prototype and I have a
couple different functions that govern
govern how he moves out of the jump
function basically just says if he's not
jumping then we're gonna change the
color and we're gonna make him jump down
here so pretty simple this is the code
to get a random color and I'm not really
gonna go into that but basically it just
makes his color change every time he
jumps every time I press the up arrow on
my keyboard
the jump function is called on the
player and this code runs pretty simple
same thing for the move left and move
right functions these functions are
going to be called in my main JavaScript
file I'm going to take a look at that in
a second and all it does is just add
half a pixel to his X & Y or X velocity
depending on which bun you press if I
press left I'm gonna subtract 0.5 pixels
from his X velocity if I press right on
my keyboard I'm gonna add 25 pixels to
his X velocity and then finally that
update function that's just gonna add
his X&Y velocity to his X&Y
locations in the canvas respectively so
now let's take a look inside of the main
J's file and see where all these are
being employed which is going to be
inside of the update function so the
reason I have my update functions all
over the place I have one for my player
I have one from our world I have one in
my main javascript file is because I'm
doing different things inside of all of
them and I want to keep all of my
objects as self-contained as possible so
for instance the player object his
update function is really simple it just
handles stuff that has to do with the
player my worlds update function only
handle stuff to do with the world so
this thought world that update is going
to be this function right here the
worlds update function only has to do
with things inside of the world the main
javascript file javascript file has an
update function that handles the
controller as well as the game so i'm
mixing these two major components of my
games logic inside of this one method
inside of my main J's file and that's
kind of where I want everything to
communicate I don't want to have those
internal references pointing to other
components inside of my game I want all
of my code to be very self-contained and
when I have it interact with other
components inside of my code I want it
to be in a safe context kind of like the
main J's file that's where I'm gonna do
most of my editing so anyway getting
information from the controller I'm just
saying is the controller being pressed
are these keys active on the keyboard
and if so I'm gonna execute a
corresponding function function on my
player object finally I'm gonna call
game dot update and game that update is
gonna go ahead and call world update
world dot update is gonna call all this
stuff and that's gonna give me these
nice school physics and take care of all
my numbers in player position and
velocity and whether or not he's
clotting and that's gonna take care of
all of the physics logic in my game it's
also gonna change the player color all
right so now I just talked about what
actually makes the game logic work and
that is of course the game class itself
stored in the game Oh to file so now I
have to talk about how I'm getting
keyboard input and relaying that to the
game class so it can actually take that
input and do something with it so I just
showed you inside the main file here
that I'm I'm conveying the keyboards
input via the controller object to the
game object and telling the game object
to do something with the players
position like move left move right or
jump and that's all gonna happen
depending on what the controller object
is doing so let's take a look at the
controller class and see how that works
so the controller class just has three
objects here a left right and up object
and those objects are going to be
controller dot button input classes so
let's take a look at the button input
class and see what it is it's really
really simple all it is is an object
that has two boolean values inside of it
one called active and one called down
now active is gonna hold the virtual
state of our button so I'll get into
that in a little bit because it has to
do with jumping and down is gonna refer
to the physical state of our button on
the keyboard so if I physically press
the up key down down is gonna be true
and if I hold that key down it's gonna
remain true the active value however is
gonna depend more on my actual games
logic so just remember keep in mind that
down refers to the physical state of the
button on my keyboard and that's what
that is going to track and active is
just going to track what that value is
of
I but an object inside of my games code
or my game logic so now that you know
what the button input class is these
three objects are gonna be button inputs
and this key down-up event handler
function is gonna be called every time I
press a key on my keyboard whether I
press it down or it comes back up this
is gonna be called it's gonna check to
see what the event type is key down or
key up so when I press a key down on the
keyboard the types gonna be key down
when are you release that key it's gonna
be key up and depending on which one it
is see they're gonna be true or false
and then I'm just gonna use the get
input method of my button input class
and hand in that down value which see
they're gonna be true or false and
that's gonna look like this it's just
gonna say if the key tracker or the
button input object if that currently is
down the state is currently down or if
the state is not equal to whatever we're
handing in then we're gonna set active
equal to whatever we're handing it and
we're just gonna set down equal to
whatever we're handing in because that's
gonna be the physical state of the
button
pretty simple maybe not so simple take a
look at the source code and fiddle
around with it because that's really the
best way to get an idea I'm just here
running over everything I'm trying to
get it done quick because this video
seems like it's gonna go long I don't
want to get to go too long but basically
this is a controller class just takes
keyboard input and I'm adding the event
listener for the controller component
inside not my engine but inside of my
main JavaScript file at the bottom if I
come all the way to the bottom you can
see I'm adding the keydown and keyup
listener to the key down-up function
which I'm defining also inside of my
main file and that is just going to call
the controller's key down-up method and
hand in the event type and the event dot
key code which we use to determine what
the type is
whether it's a down press or an up press
and the keycode is just going to
determine which key on the keyboard and
pressing so 37 38 and 39 are the left up
and right arrow keys on the keyboard so
basically this controller class just
gets keyboard input and then we relay
that input to the game component right
here in the main JS file inside of its
update function which is called on every
frame of animation managed by our engine
which I'm going to talk about later on
in this video so really simply just
checks to see if the left right and up
keys are active and then it goes ahead
and it calls a player movement function
so move left move right or jump so where
the active value comes into play here is
when the player is jumping so notice
that I'm actually setting the virtual
state of the controller up button input
to false I'm changing the active value
to false so that's gonna give me the
ability to press my key once and hold it
down and not have my player jump again
if I were to come in and comment this
line of code out like this and just go
like this comment this guy out save my
file come over here to my browser
refresh now I'm just gonna jump up and
down continuously now this might be
desirable for some people's for some
games this might be what you want but
for other games you're not gonna want to
keep on jumping just because you have
the key press down so if that's
something you want in your game not
having the player jump up and down
continuously as your button is pressed
in this controller class right here and
these button input objects here with
this dual virtual and physical button
state tracker objects here these boolean
values this is gonna allow you to
prevent your player from just jumping up
and down continuously and you're gonna
get functionality that looks like this
instead you're just gonna be able to
jump one time and only jump when you
press the key rather than jumping just
continuously if you have a key held down
all right so now that you know how to
define the player object in the world
object in our game class and you know
how to get user input to actually
control this guy and move them around
the screen the only thing left is how to
draw this guy so how we're drawing the
player object and the world itself to
this canvas element is with the display
class so inside of the display class I
just define a buffer in a context of my
canvas so these are two 2d rendering
contexts canvas rendering context
context is the rendering context of the
on-screen canvas that you see on screen
buffer is just an off-screen canvas that
is going to be sized perfectly to match
our world height and width so if we come
back into our game and scroll down here
the buffer canvas is going to be sized
72 pixels high and 128 pixels wide and
that is actually going to happen all the
way at the bottom of our main j/s file
and the reason for that is just so
everything scales the way it should so
I'm setting that up right here in the
initialization portion of my main J's
file so let's get back into display and
talk a little bit more about it so I've
added a couple different functions I
have the fill function or method all it
does is take a color and draw it to the
buffer which remembers the off-screen
canvas which is then drawn by the render
function to our on-screen campus it
draws this off-screen buffer canvas to
the on-screen display canvas that you
actually see in the browser window so
the fill method just fills the buffer
with color render renders that buffer to
the screen draw rectangle just draws
this rectangle here that's what I'm
handing in in terms of X Y width and
height and color and it just draws that
to the buffer as well I'm actually
rounding down the X&Y positions of the
rectangle that I'm handing in this way
it doesn't render it on a half pixel so
let's see what happens when I take this
code out first let's take a look at what
this guy actually looks like moving
around the screen so pretty smooth
nothing weird going on all the edges
look pretty straight if I come in here
and I just put
in X & Y though let's take a look and
see if anything changes as you can see
it looks a little bit funky I mean it's
hard to tell because I have this
background let's actually go in here and
change the background color of my game
to something else here let's uh let's
make it black instead zero zero zero
zero zero zero that's gonna give me
black I'm gonna come in here refresh my
screen take a look at the player
character you see how his edges are kind
of messed up they're kind of wavering a
little bit kind of looks like he's just
fading around instead of just sitting on
the exact pixel he's meant to sit on
well that is actually because he's
sitting on half pixels from time to time
and you can fix that by rounding down
the values you pass into your draw
method so we can go from this which
looks a little bit funky to this which
now looks really sharp and not so funky
at all it's based it's basically the
best we can get on a html5 canvas so now
let me set back my background color to
the way it was before so we could have a
nice fading effect that follows the
character around refresh my screen and
so that's what I'm gonna use to draw my
rectangle to the screen and round him to
the nearest full pixel location with
math dot floor so he doesn't get that
weird blur around the edges now let's
take a look at the main j/s file and
that's where all of these are gonna be
called actually I think inside of
actually no I'm wrong let's just take a
look at the main J's file and see where
these guys are called I think it's gonna
be inside of the render function I don't
look at this code in a little bit so we
have displayed up fill and by the way
the render function is gonna be called
by our game engine which is our game
loop on every frame of the animation so
30 times every second so we call display
dot fill that's gonna fill our
background color with this nice dark
gray here we're gonna call draw
rectangle and hand in the game dot world
dot player which is a rectangle we're
gonna hand in all those values as well
as the
color value and finally we're gonna call
displayed out render and that's gonna
draw the buffer that we just filled with
the background color and drew the
rectangle too and we're gonna draw that
that buffer to the final display canvas
now one more thing I want to talk about
here because this is pretty simple stuff
is the resize functionality so the
resize functionality is gonna take care
of scaling my onscreen canvas it's also
gonna take care of keeping the aspect
ratio of the game world which you
remember has the height and width
coordinates it's gonna keep that aspect
ratio from the game world and the buffer
to the final display canvas so we get a
nice square rectangle every time so
what's important about that well if we
come down here I told you that we're
gonna set our buffers canvas height and
width to the gameworld height and width
now if I were to change this and say
height times 0.5 obviously that would
warp our game a little bit so let's take
a look at that and what that looks like
well kind of cut off half the world but
you can see that when I jump up the
player is actually a lot taller than he
is wide by about twice as much so let's
set back that that back to normal and go
ahead and take a look at the resize
function which I'm adding to the window
that handles all of that stuff so
resizes right here it's gonna call
display dot resize it's gonna hand in
document.documentelement.clientheight
it's gonna subtract 32 pixels from both
of those to give us this nice 16 pixel
margin on either side of our display
canvas which I have to refresh so it
goes back to the way it's supposed to be
so that's what that's doing those 32
pixels then it's gonna hand in an aspect
ratio of our game world which is going
to be just the height divided by the
width of our game world so now let's
take a look inside of the display
objects resize method and see what it's
actually doing so here I am inside of
the resize method and as you can see
it's not super complicated is actually
pretty simple it's basically just gonna
say if the height and
ratio that we handed in from
document.documentelement crime with
incline height - 32 pixels to give us
that nice 16 pixel margin on each side
it's gonna say if that ratio is greater
than the height width ratio of the world
object the game world then if that
height width if the screens height width
ratio is greater than the height width
ratio of the world then we're gonna set
the canvases height to the width times
the ratio and we're gonna set the
canvases with to the width of the screen
so right now we have a max width
scenario otherwise we don't have a max
width scenario we have a max height
scenario and it's gonna set the canvases
height to the max height and it's gonna
set the width to the height divided by
the height width ratio so this code is
basically gonna allow me to do this if I
come in here and I change the scale my
window as you can see it's always gonna
keep it centered right now I have a max
height situation and I have a shorter
width in my game world but the aspect
ratio remains the same and here I'm
gonna go back down somewhere around here
I'm gonna change over from a max height
situation to a max width situation and
now you can see my display canvas
gradually getting smaller in height so
that's pretty cool that's the display
function takes care of resizing the
canvas and maintaining that nice aspect
ratio so our game can scale nicely
across many different devices
all right so now I'm gonna do a brief
run-through of my fixed time step game
engine and this is the game engine
classes in the engine file I haven't
changed it since part 1 of this series
it's exactly the same as it was although
I did add in this accumulated time
variable definition because it wasn't in
here it was actually being added later
right here so I just fixed that but it's
basically exactly the same so what a
fixed time step game loop does is it
causes your game to update and draw a at
a fixed rate as time passes and it does
that by taking a time step value which
in this case is gonna be 1,000 divided
by 30 if I come over to my main j/s
where I actually instantiate this I am
passing 1,000 divided by 30 which is
roughly 30 3.3333 repeating forever and
that is going to be the number of
milliseconds that I'm going to call
render and update on so every 33 point 3
3 milliseconds I'm gonna call render and
update and the render and update
functions are just right here you've
seen them throughout this video and
they're basically just gonna update my
game logic and render the changed game
state to the screen hop back inside of
the engine and talk about this game loop
some more all right so we've got our
time step and that's gonna be in this
case about thirty-three point three
three milliseconds and so every 33 point
three three milliseconds I'm gonna call
the update and render function I passed
in they're gonna be stored right here
and I'm gonna keep track of how much
time has passed in the accumulated time
variable so every time thirty-three
point three three milliseconds passes
hopefully our our game is updating close
to that but anything that overflows is
gonna be stored in accumulated time so
let's say 33 point three three is our
minimum time step and that's exactly
what it is but let's say
requestanimationframe which is what
we're using to update our game logic
fires at 40 milliseconds now we're gonna
have about what is that
seven six
something about six milliseconds left
over and we're going to store that an
accumulated time and when accumulated
time reaches our time step or 33.3 three
we're gonna update or call update one
more time
so basically we're storing all the time
that passes in accumulated time and
we're just taking bites out of that
accumulated time we're taking 33
millisecond bites out of our accumulated
time the time value is just going to be
the last time our run function executes
and this is just gonna be the looping
function this is gonna be the function
that loops over and over again a lot of
game engines will call this cycle some
call it loop I'm just calling my run
because engines run so this is going to
be one run of the game loop so inside of
the run function we're adding the
current timestamp that's handed to us by
requestanimationframe we're subtracting
the current time or the last time our
game executed from the current time and
we're adding that to accumulated time so
let's say that our the last time our
game executed was at 100 milliseconds
and we're just now getting in a new call
to the run function from
requestanimationframe and it's gonna
happen at 140 milliseconds so we're
gonna have 140 milliseconds minus 100
milliseconds and 40 milliseconds is
going to go into accumulated time so now
we have 40 milliseconds in accumulated
time we're just gonna set the the new
most recent time value to the current
time value but just remember 40
milliseconds in accumulated time here is
where the fixed time step game loop
really shines because this oh actually
this is just a safety I'm not going to
talk about but but this is where it
really shines the while loop so remember
we have 40 milliseconds of accumulated
time and we have our 33 I'm gonna round
that down to 33 our 33 milliseconds in
our time step so for T is greater than
33 so while for T where our accumulated
time is greater than our time step we
are going to reduce our accumulated time
by the time step we're gonna call update
and we're going to
this updated flag to true but don't
worry about that too much so then we're
gonna loop again and see if that's true
again and we subtracted 33 from 40 so
that's going to give us 7 and 7 is no
longer greater than our time step so
we're not going to update again but
let's say that accumulated time was
equal to 70 ok so now we have 70 70 is
greater than 33 so we're gonna call
update then we're gonna try to loop
again well 70 minus 33 what is that 47
is that accurate anyway 47 is still
gonna be greater whatever it is it's
still gonna be greater than 33 so we're
gonna update again so even if we didn't
have another request animation frame
event fire and we didn't update the
screen again we're still gonna be
updating twice on the next time
requestanimationframe fires and gives us
a new run command or we're gonna call
run again so we're gonna be keeping up
with time no matter what happens so even
if our game runs really slow and laggy
it's still going to keep up with time
it's gonna run at the same rate
basically on any device regardless of
how slow it is unless as the device is
so slow that it just can't handle the
game and then it will crash but that's
that's not something you really should
worry about unless your game is crashing
all devices but if your game is just
crashing the you know computers from
1995 then you shouldn't worry about it
but basically the fixed time step game
loop just says if too much time has
passed or if a certain amount of time
has passed we're gonna update our game
at whatever rate we want it to update
until we have caught up with however
much time has passed and that's a really
great functionality of fixed time step
game loops and it's a great reason to
add them in to any game that you're
writing so now down here we have the
updated flag basically we turn that flag
on we set it to true any time we do an
update and then if it is true if we have
updated then we're gonna call the render
function and that's just going to draw
our game so why is this good well let's
say
accumulated time only has 20
milliseconds in it but we need 33
milliseconds to justify an update
otherwise we'd be going faster than we
want to update well if that's the case
then this never fires we never update
our game and if we don't update our game
nothing has changed and anything we draw
is just gonna be a waste of CPU or GPU
so we don't want to draw anything that
hasn't been updated or changed so if no
update has occurred update updated stays
false and we don't draw and finally
inside of the run function we just make
another call to the handle run method
and the handle run method is just down
here is just an arrow function that
calls the engine dot run method now the
reason I'm using an arrow function is
because if you've worked with event
listeners or requestanimationframe
before the this keyword inside of
whatever function you hand into your
event listener as your event handler or
requestanimationframe as your response
to a request animation frame event
firing is going to point to the object
that you request the frame or add an
event listener to so in this case it's
the window so I don't want this to refer
to window I want this to refer to my
actual engine object so by using this
arrow function I can actually make this
refer to my engine object rather than
the window so that's the only reason I
have that kind of setup as an arrow
function there to make sure that the
this keyword is referring to engine
instead of window otherwise I would have
to have a reference to engine inside of
the engine and that just is really it
just seems really sloppy to me so I set
up the era function and that's what that
does and anyway I hope that was a good
explanation of a fixed time step engine
and it probably wasn't the best I was
kind of going through a really fast it's
really cold in this room where I'm
recording and I'm kind of I'm like
freezing to death so don't hold it
against me I should turn up the heat but
you know just I'm doing what I'm doing
here so hopefully that was a good enough
explanation of a fixed time step game
loop
and if not definitely take a look at the
source code I commented everything in
here so you guys can get a better
understanding of the code as you read
through it line by line in this video I
showed you how to lay the groundwork for
any platforming game so far I've
implemented keyboard input simple
platforming physics scaling for multiple
devices and a fixed time step game loop
to handle updating your game at a
consistent rate no matter what device is
on which is perhaps the most important
thing you could take away from this
video I'm gonna show you how to draw a
tiled background from a one-dimensional
tile map I'm gonna talk about the
example program and what I've added
since part two then I'm gonna talk about
how to load the tile sheet image and
store in a tile sheet class finally I'll
show you the tile map in the game class
and how its drawn
all righty guys let's take a look at
what has changed since part two if I
come over here in the browser
first I'm gonna real quick I'm gonna go
ahead and I'm gonna pull up part two so
you guys can see it and that is right
here I'm gonna press enter load up part
two and this is part two so as you can
see I have some jumping physics I get
keyboard input but there's no tiled
background and to make this game I'm
definitely gonna need a cool tiled
background so let's go over to part
three and check out what we've done
there alright so this is part three and
as you can see it's a lot better I still
have the same game physics where my
character jumps around and moves around
same fluid physics exact same physics
code the only difference now is the
world is a different size and I have a
tile map inside of it also the color of
the character is just a solid white and
gray the reason I did that was to more
closely resemble the player sprite we're
gonna be using which is this little
rabbit dude and basically that's it
that's all the changes that have
happened in part three since part two
the files where the changes occurred our
display game and main everything else
I'm using the controller class from part
two if I come into my directory here I'm
gonna be using the controller class from
part two and I'm going to be using that
file and I'm also going to be using the
engine class from part one but this is
part three and these are the only three
files that you need to worry about if
you've already watched part one in two
so anyway on to the rest of the video
the first thing we need to worry about
for this application is how we're gonna
get our sprite sheet PNG image into our
JavaScript so we can actually do
something with it and have it render
over here on the screen and show up on
the background of our canvas elements so
first we need to define some sort of
container for our sprite sheet image and
it's different variables and we do that
inside of the display class so here's my
display class it's one of the files that
has changed since part 2 and inside of
it I define a class called pile sheet I
come down to the bottom here here's my
tile she cost it's just a really simple
object it has an image inside of it
this image object is gonna store our
tile sheet or our sprite sheet and then
it records the tile size and I'm just
gonna hand in 16 because each one of our
tiles is 16 by 16 pixels and the number
of columns and our tile sheet so I think
that's 8 off top of my head but if we
come over here and we actually count
them we're gonna have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
different tiles kind of hard to tell but
there's 8 tiles or 8 columns in this map
eight tiles across or eight columns not
just eight tiles in the map obviously
there's more but so we have to define
this tile sheet class and it's just
gonna have an image which is gonna be
our image it's gonna have the tile size
and it's gonna have the number of
columns in our tile sheet image now that
we have this we can actually go about
loading this PNG image into our
JavaScript so we can do something with
it where that happens is the main j/s
file for part 3 so if I come down to the
bottom of my file here you can see that
I am setting the image of my tile sheet
object in the display class I'm setting
the source of that image to the rabbit
trap dot PNG and that's gonna start
loading the rabbit trap PNG image here
into the tile sheet objects image and
when it's done loading it's gonna fire
this event listener for loaded so it's
gonna say okay my image just loaded I
haven't
listener for that let's call this
function the event handler function for
a load event there I'm gonna resize the
screen that's just gonna resize the
browser window or not the browser window
but resize our canvas to fit the browser
window rather and it's gonna call engine
dot start that's gonna start our game
loop off and then we're actually going
to be able to use that graphic because
we start our engine before the graphic
is fully loaded we're gonna try to draw
graphics that just aren't loaded yet and
that's a problem so make sure that your
graphic is fully loaded with an event
listener for load before you actually
start your engine also down here this
extra parameter once : true that just
tells this event listener to only fire
once and after it's done it just junks
it sends it to the trash sends it to
garbage collection we don't have to
worry about removing this event listener
from our tile sheet image because this
parameter here just takes care of it
all right so now that we've loaded our
tile sheet image into our JavaScript we
actually have to get these individual
images out of this sprite sheet or tile
sheet we have to draw them to different
locations on the canvas to create
something of a tiled map like you see
here so how do we do that well it starts
out in the game class and I have a map
inside of my game class inside of the
world and basically it's just a big long
array of values that point to different
locations in the tile sheet so the best
way I can explain this to you is by just
giving you an example and I'm gonna look
down here in the bottom right of my
numeric tile map at these three values
143 and 10 now these values correspond
to locations inside of my tile sheet
graphic and they also correspond to
these locations on the map so this is
the one tile this here is going to be
the 43 tile and this over here is going
to be the 10 tile and as you can see you
can kind of make that connection those 3
tiles are going to be in this bottom
right hand corner of the map so now
let's take a look at these tiles inside
of the sprite sheet itself we're gonna
have one so that's going to be for this
example it's going to be at position 1
in our map normally I start at 0 I start
counting at 0 but for this example I'm
gonna start counting at 1 so tile 1 is
just gonna be this corner tile and as
you can see right here in the map it is
that corner tile these two tiles are the
same so tile 1 is just gonna be this one
right here and if you think about it
makes sense because this is the first
tile index in the map so we'll just go 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and remember this is
tile 10 we have our 10 tile right here
and it's just a plain clear brown tile
and if I come back to my map you can see
that that is in fact valued at tile 10
so now you kind of understand or
hopefully you understand the correlation
between these values in a one
dimensional tile map and
the images on screen as well as the
locations of those images in the tile
sheet image itself but just because we
have the map doesn't mean we're actually
drawing this stuff to the screen we
actually have to write a function for
that and that function is going to be
inside of the display class and it's a
function called draw map and it's just
gonna take the map which is just that
array value so it's just gonna be this
I'm gonna hand in and the number of
columns in the map and we have 12
columns on our map I define that here
twelve columns if you can't actually
have one two three four all the way to
twelve columns inside of my map if you
look at the screen you can count 12
tiles across so this draw map function
is just gonna take the map and it's
gonna take the columns and it's gonna
loop through every single value in the
map so it's gonna loop through every
single number right here and it's gonna
get the value there I subtract one from
it and that's going to if I don't
subtract one this is what happens if I
just add 0 let's take a look real quick
and see what happens and I'll show you a
really simple way to remedy this which I
didn't use because I use the tile map
editor to make this because I have
really complex tiles here but this is
what it looks like and it's because all
of my tile values are offset by one now
I set it back to negative one the reason
for that is in my tile map these are all
one higher than they should be so this
should actually be 17 this should be 48
this should be 49 this should be 31
they're all offset by one that's just
because the tile map editor I use which
is tiled exports the comma separated
values starting at 1 instead of 0 I
didn't feel like going through and
changing all these so hopefully this
doesn't throw you guys off too much
don't worry about it when you make your
Maps just make sure you have the right
values starting at index 0 in your tile
sheet so basically instead of this being
1 it would be 0 and you start counting
from 0 but if you want to use a map
editor like tiled and you don't mind
just having that offset it's really
simple all you have to do is subtract 1
from the tile value and you're good to
go
so anyway that aside plus again
to how I'm actually placing those images
from the source onto the buffer and then
drawing it on the screen so I get the
different values or I get the value of
the specific tile in the map that I'm
looping over I get the source X&Y
position that I'm gonna cut it out of
the tile sheet at and that's what this
code right here does it just takes the
number of columns in the tile sheet
takes the value that gets the column and
then you multiply by the tile size to
get the actual position to cut out of
inside of the tile sheet image didn't
mean to do that but that's basically
just getting the x position to start
cutting out of come back in here then we
have the y value that's gonna get the Y
position to start cutting out of and
then when you get the source that you're
gonna hand in the source x + y which is
just these two values here and the tile
height and tile width which I just have
one of its tile size and it's 16 pixels
so source X and source Y are gonna get
me to the appropriate tile say I am at
tile 8 that's gonna put me right here it
actually be a value of 7 but that's
gonna put me right here and then I'm
gonna cut 16 pixels wide and 16 pixels
high so the Y value will be 0 the x
value would be 128 minus 16 to get me
right here to the left side of this tile
and then because 128 is the width of my
map and it's just gonna cut this tile
out it's pretty simple
come back here display look at the rest
of this destination it kind of looks
like the same kind of mathematical
formula I'm just using the number of
columns in my game world which you
remember is 12 so that's the number of
columns in this map and I'm multiplying
that by 16 as well now I guess I should
be using the game dot world dot tile
size but I'm just using 16 for both so I
guess it doesn't really matter and then
finally you're going to use this
information to cut the appropriate image
out of your tile sheet image and draw it
into your buffer which is then going to
be drawn to the final on screen canvas
so you're just gonna say I want to draw
an image to my buffer from the tile
sheet image and I'm gonna cut the image
out of the tile sheet out at source X
and source Y and tile size width and
tile size height I'm going to draw it to
the buffer at Destination X and
destination Y at the 16 by 16 width and
height so that's all that does and then
if I come out here into my main J's file
and I come down to the up rather to the
render function you can see that I'm
calling the display dot draw map
function I'm handing in the game that
world thought map and the game got World
columns into that function and that is
how you draw all those tiles to the game
screen I talked about how to load a
sprite sheet image into your JavaScript
how to create a tile map array and how
to draw tiles from the sprite sheet to
to display canvas if you're worried that
there was a lot of code I didn't cover
don't all you need to know is how these
basic components work together in order
to build them yourself chances are your
application structure will be different
from mine so don't focus too much on
what I didn't show you and instead try
to build the components I'm talking
about into your own application this
stuff really works and if you need the
source code you can find it on my github
page I'm going to show you the aspiring
game programmer how to add pixel perfect
professional quality tile-based
collision detection and response to a
platforming game I'm going to talk about
what's changed since part three then I'm
going to go over the three main
components of my collision system
there's the broad phase the routing
function and finally the narrow phase
let's take a look at what's changed
since part three so this is part four it
looks just like part three for the most
part except now I have collision
detection and response between my player
character and the game world so as you
can see I'm moving smoothly across the
tops of the tiles jumping up along the
sides of the tiles I'm not getting hung
up on any of the edges anywhere I can
jump through the bombs of these platform
tiles basically I have pixel perfect
tile based collision detection and
response and everything looks and works
the way you would expect it to and it's
how
platforming game so now that you know
what the example is all about let's take
a look at what's changed in the code so
the only two files that have changed
since part three are the game file which
holds the game class and the display
file which holds the display class
display had a minor change since part 3
if you remember part 3 I had an issue
with the export values for my tile map
because I use the tile map editor and
all the values were offset by one so I
just changed this function and I changed
my tile map values to what they're
supposed to be so I got rid the offset
as you see I have the comment no longer
subtracting one take a look at part
three so you can see what I'm talking
about also in here in the draw player
class I changed math up floor to math
around in this line and this line here
and the reason is because it just rounds
my player to the appropriate spot that
he's gonna be drawn in more smoothly so
those are two really minor changes in
the display file inside the game file a
lot has changed I've added the collider
function I've added my collision map
which is this guy right here
a collision map is different than the
graphical map for the tiles themselves
that you see on the screen these are for
the collision shapes down here I've
amended my collide objects function
inside of the world class to do the
broad phase collision detection and
response that are these functions right
here then I've also added the collider
class the collider class takes care of
the routing function as well as all of
the narrow phase collision methods like
collide platform bottom so cloud
platform bottom would be called whenever
you physically Clyde you at the top of
the player with the bottom of a platform
so I'm jumping up and Clyde platform
bottom is firing every time my player
hits his head on the bottom of that tile
there so that's what that does then I've
also added a base class for the player
objects called objects and that's nested
inside a game that world the object is
basically just a simple rectangle class
and I'm gonna talk about X old and wild
and why we need those later on in a
different part in this video but
basically the odd
class is just the superclass
of the player cost now basically the
player is gonna inherit all of these
values from object and it's gonna get
all of these neat little helper
functions to get the different sides of
his rectangle so that's all that does
and then down here you can see I'm
actually extending the object class
inside of the player constructor and
down here I'm actually extending the
player prototype off of the object
prototype with object design so those
are all the changes in part four
stay tuned for the rest of the video
there are three main components to this
approach to tile-based collision
detection response and those are the
broad phase the routing function and the
narrow phase and they're all centered
around having a collision map full of
collision tile values each value
represents a different shape or
collision shape so for instance if I hop
over here I can jump through the bomb
this tile but not fall through the top
of this tile here I can call at the
bottom I can card with the right side
and I can collide with the top of that
as well this tile over here these two I
can collide with the left side so all of
these tile values correspond to
collision shapes that have different
sides so the broad phase gets what tile
my player character is standing on it
determines what the value of that tile
is that my player character is standing
on gets that value from the collision
map it then hands that value as well as
the player object into the routing
function the routing function checks the
value in a switch statement and it says
okay well let's check for instance I'm
standing on top of tile one here this is
tile one so the routing function would
say okay you're colliding with tile type
1 and for tile type 1 I'm going to call
a certain set of narrow phase collision
detection and response methods so the
broad phase determines what the tile
value is the routing function determines
which narrow phase functions to call and
the narrow phase does the final
collision detection and response and
that's how the system works so stay
tuned and I'm going to go into the code
that makes that stuff work you
detail alright so now I want to talk
about the broad phase collision method
and that is going to be the collide
object function which is located inside
of the game that world class so I'm
gonna come down here and show you what
this broad-faced does the whole function
all it does is first it checks for
collision with the outsides of the world
and that's going to be this right here
that's from part three that's pretty
simple stuff and then the other thing it
does is it checks all of the different
corners all four corners of our player
character so I have these four chunks of
code I've one here for the top left I
have one for the top right one for the
bottom left and one for the bottom right
and that's the end of the function so
this is the entire broad phase just
these four chunks and this chunk up here
which does collision with the boundaries
of the world so let's take a look at the
first chunk that tests for broad phase
collision with the collision map with
the top left corner of our player
characters so what these are are a row
and a column value inside of our
collision maps so top is going to be the
row that the top side of our players in
and left is going to be the column that
the left side of our players and so this
is gonna be the top of our player this
is gonna be the left side of our player
and this is gonna be the row that the
top is in now if I move the player over
here this is gonna be the row that he's
in and if I check the left side this is
gonna be the column that he's in if I
move them over here now the left side of
the players in this column so pretty
simple the math that we use to get the
row and column and convert it from the
physical X Y position of the player to
the one-dimensional index or of a row or
column value it's not really
one-dimensional it's two dimensional is
just simplified basically you just get
the top of the object which is the Y
position of the top of the object you
divide by tile size that gives you the
row of the top and then you do the same
thing for the column you just get the
left side of the object which is right
here u divided by tile size that's going
to give you the column value and then
you're gonna go ahead and convert those
the row and the column into a index
inside of our map array or collision map
array and you just do that by
multiplying the row by the number of
columns inside of the collision map ours
was 12 and then you add the column that
the player is standing in so that's the
row of the side of the player multiplied
by the number of columns in the
collision map plus the column of the
side of the player pretty simple and
then you go ahead and you hand in that
value as well as the row and column
positions of the tile multiplied by tile
size to give you the actual X&Y position
of the tile so for instance if I was
gonna get the top left of my player that
would be right here
he's inside of this tile the top and
left values multiplied by the tile size
is going to give you this position right
here which is gonna be the x and y
position of the tile so we're gonna hand
all that information in to the colliders
collide method and that's gonna be the
routing function you're gonna hand in
the value you're gonna hand any object
you're gonna hand in the left side of
the tile and you're gonna hand in the
top side of the tile you're also gonna
hand in the tile size and then you just
go ahead and you do this for every
corner of the player so we just did the
top left down here we're gonna do the
top right then we do the bottom left
bottom left there we go and we do the
bottom right and we just do that for all
four corners now you might be thinking
well you're redefining some values that
you're reusing so why not just define
for instance here we go when we find a
good example here right so this is
checking the top right corner right this
right here and this is checking the
bottom right corner
well I'm defining right two times but
why would I do that well the reason I'm
doing that is because here I'm defining
right and I'm checking for collision if
I have a collision and I respond to it
my player character is going to move and
right as I defined it here might not be
the same anymore so down here when I'm
getting the right side of player again
I'm not going to want to use this old
value for right I'm going to want to get
the right
cited my player again because it might
be different than it was when I checked
collision with the top right so I
checked collision with the top right if
there is in fact the collision up here
it's gonna move my player and now I
check oh this is the top right I keep
getting confused there but then when I
check the bottom right if I moved that
value is gonna have to be redefined to
get the appropriate new location of the
players right side after he had
collision resolved with the top right
corner so this is the broad phase it's
not as complicated as you think it's
really simple the math is really simple
you're just getting a value out of an
array based on a player's column and row
or row and column rather and then you're
handing all that information into the
routing function we're gonna take a look
at the routing function in the next part
of the video now let's take a look at
the routing functions so I'm gonna come
down here to the routing function and
that is gonna be in the game that world
that Collider class and it's gonna be
called collide so the collide function
is my routing function and all it does
is it takes the tile value the object in
tiles X&Y position as well as the tile
size which is the tiles width and height
and it takes all that from broad-faced
and it hands in the value of the tile
into a big switch statement which then
routes you and that's why I called a
routing function it routes you to the
appropriate narrow phase collision
methods and it also does some tweaking
to the tiles so for instance case 1 if I
move my player down here I'm actually
gonna be standing on a one tile I know
for a fact this here is a one tile and
it's gonna call collide platform top and
it's gonna hand in the object so that's
gonna be my player character it's gonna
hand in tile why not tile X because we
don't need it in this case we just need
to know what the top of the tile is
gonna be now if I want this to be a
little bit lower say I want to make a
half tile I'm just gonna hack this right
now but I'm gonna put in plus eight and
I know for a fact that 8 is half of my
tile height so that's gonna be didn't
mean to do that
that's gonna be my change that I made I
say
my file I'm going to refresh my screen
now as you can see all the one tiles
that I'm colliding with are going to
have half height so this tile right here
I'm now going to be colliding with a
value that's a little bit lower
interesting so I can take my narrow
phase functions and I can tweak them a
little bit inside of my routing function
and that's gonna give me the ability to
create a whole bunch of different tile
types however I want so all the
different shapes are going to be defined
basically inside of the routing function
and all it really does is gets the tile
value and links it to a certain set of
narrow phase functions let's take a look
at let's see what I got here let's take
a look at something a little more
complex first I'm gonna have to see what
tiles are what cuz I can't think right
off the top of my head what those values
actually stand for but if I look at my
map I'm gonna come over here to a 13
tile and that looks to be at the left
side of this T right here so 13 is going
to be oh wait I forgot to refresh my
screen let's refresh and get
functionality back to normal so 13 is
going to be this tile right here that
I'm standing on now so let's take a look
in the routing function at the 13 tile
all right here we go it's gonna call the
methods collide platform top cloud
platform left and collide platform
bottom and the reason for that is
because I'm gonna Clyde with the left
side of this tile card with the left
side maybe if I can actually hit it
if I with the left side I'm gonna clap
at the bottom and I'm also gonna collide
with the top so those are the three
sides that I'm gonna be able to collide
with if I happen to meet a tile with a
value of 13 now the reason I have some
of these functions nested inside of
if-statements is because I can only
collide with one of those sides of a
tile at a time so I can only clad with
the top and if I do I can't possibly be
colliding with the left or the bottom
certainly not the bottom if I'm coming
from the top how would I call it at the
bottom so I use these if statements too
early out of my routing function and not
have to execute checks for these other
two functions which is great
because for any given tile were only
checking collisions on sides until we
actually do collision and then we just
exit out we don't have to check the rest
of the collision so Clyde platform top
is gonna be in this if statement if I
Clyde with the platform top then I'm no
longer gonna have to check for colliding
with the left side or colliding with the
bottom side of the tile now inside of my
narrow phase my function returns true if
I do in fact have a collision and it is
resolved and it returns false if no
collision was detected and nothing was
resolved and if that's the case its
false
they'll just jump down to this next
narrow phase collision method called
that if there's no collision there it
will jump finally to the last method in
the case and called that and if that
doesn't return true then there is no
collision and nothing gets resolved so
that's the routing function pretty
simple that's how it works
in previous tutorials on how to do this
systems tile-based collision system I
used an array and I used objects object
references to get these but actually
it's much much faster to use a switch
statement so that's why I made the
switch to a switch statement pun
intended there so anyway next step onto
the narrow phase now let's look at the
narrow phase and that is going to be
farther down inside of the collider
classes prototype so inside the collider
classes prototype I have four functions
and those are collide platform bottom
high platform left's collide platform
right and collide platform top and
awesomely enough with these four
functions we can do collision detection
and response with all of the different
tile types basically any tile that has
four sides we can take these four
functions and combine them to get all
kinds of different combinations up to 15
combinations which is as many
combinations as you can have with a four
sided tile so let's take a look at let's
see here cloud platform top where I got
was on alright let's take a look at
cloud platform
hop and see how this actually works so
from the routing function you're gonna
get the object and you're gonna get the
top side of the tile so top side of the
tile is just gonna be whatever the top
of the tile is that you're standing on
so right now I'm standing on this tile I
have my object I have the top of my tile
and we're just gonna run an if statement
that checks to see if the bottom of our
player character is greater than the
tile top and if it is then we run this
code but wait there's more there's an
end in here so we've got to see what
that is - we're also gonna check to see
if the bottom of the player from the
last frame of animation is above the
tile top now if you didn't include this
it would still work but it would not
work as smoothly as you see here so
let's go ahead and comment this out and
see what happens when we don't use the
old position from the last frame of the
player character I'm gonna comment that
out I'm gonna save I'm gonna come in
here I'm gonna refresh and now let's see
what we get everything might work
perfectly but oh wait how about that I
just jumped right through that tile now
the reason for that is the when I jump
up the top left and top right corners of
my player are going to enter into this
tile space the broad phase is going to
detect that it's going to hand the
information to the routing function and
the routing function is going to call
collide platform top now cloud platform
top without doing this check on the last
position that the bottom of the player
was in the last frame of animation
without that it's just gonna check to
see is the bottom of the player greater
than the tile top and if it is set it to
the top of the tile so that's what's
happening when I enter into the tile its
text that the player was below the top
of the tile and it just sets it right to
the top so that's the functionality
you're gonna get without this when you
add this in basically what's happening
is it's saying hang on let me refresh
real quick basically it's saying okay
the bottom of my player maybe
inside of this tile but if on the last
frame it wasn't up here and therefore
entering into this tile between frames
so on frame one he's gonna be here on
frame two with the force of gravity he's
gonna be down here inside the tile he's
going to be entering in through the top
and collide platform top is going to
detect that inside of this if statement
because the bottom on the current frame
is going to be below the tile top and
the bottom on the last frame is going to
be above the tile top so that's going to
be true and then we're going to get the
appropriate response that we expect and
we're no longer gonna jump through the
bottom of the tile and get that kind of
glitchy looking collision response so
now let's take a look at what happens
after we do that after we Clyde with the
top of the tile so gonna kayo at the top
of my tile here this is gonna be true
the bottom on the current frame is gonna
be slightly below the bottom on the
previous frame is gonna be above and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna set the
bottom of the object I'm gonna set this
bottom of the object to the tile top and
I'm gonna subtract this little value
here I'm gonna get into why I subtract
that value in a minute I'm gonna take a
look at another function because that
better explains why I do that I'm gonna
set Y velocity to zero this way gravity
doesn't keep increasing and eventually
pull me through the tile all together
I'm gonna set jumping to fall so I can
jump again and I'm gonna return true so
I can tell the routing function not to
do any more narrow phase collision calls
so now let's take a look at this little
value and see what it does but I'm gonna
do it in the context of the collide
platform left function because that also
has a similar problem cloud platform
right and cloud platform bottoms don't
have this problem and it has to do with
rounding so let's just comment this out
and see what happens but first I'm going
to show you the desired functionality so
right now I'm colliding with the left
side of these two tiles and it's calling
collide platform left to do that
collision resolution so as you can see I
can jump up and down and it's as you
would expect I'm jumping up and falling
down nothing is broken yet so let me
comment this out and break the code I'm
not really breaking the code
it's all gonna work the same it's just
not gonna have the desired effect I'm
gonna refresh my screen and I'm gonna
come over here and I'm gonna do this
again now when I jump I land on top of
the tile and the reason for that is
because when I'm falling down I'm
actually gonna be in this tile space
with the right side of my player so the
right side of my player when I'm falling
down into this tile space is actually
going to be in this tile space just
looking at it with a naked eye it looks
like he's fully inside of this column
but really his right side is just barely
inside of this column over here so
unless we subtract that point zero one
or some tiny number doesn't have to be
point zero one it could probably be
point one or point zero zero one if you
prefer because we subtract that we are
pushing the player-character out of this
tile into this column and he's no longer
touching this after he enters or exits
collision with the left side of this
tile space so let's refresh and see what
that good functionality looks like now
I'm colliding with the left side of this
column this tile right here it's pushing
me out of collision and it's actually
pushing me out of the tile space
entirely by point zero one pixels so
when I jump I am fully inside of this
column as you would expect and I'm no
longer going to be colliding with these
tiles unless I press right on my
keyboard and move the player into them
so that's why I have to subtract that
little value
now before I stop talking about the
narrow phase collision let me just talk
a little bit about object I get old
right and how we actually do that so
basically all we're doing is on every
frame we are saving the last frames
player position and we're getting the
new frames new player position so where
that happens is inside of the player
object you actually come out here and
look so we can actually see the code a
little bit the player class now extends
the object class and inside of the
object class we have this is the object
class right here inside of this we have
some information to describe a rectangle
and we're also going to have
the ex-old and why old values so keep
that in mind we have a X&Y location we
have the X&Y location from the previous
frame of animation so if I come down
here to the player class and I come down
here to his update function this is
where we're going to be keeping track of
this X old and Y old are going to be
updated on every frame of animation to
equal that frames current X&Y position
and then we're going to update X&Y to be
as fresh as possible in the new frame so
we're basically just keeping track of
the player's old X&Y position from the
last frame and his current X&Y position
from the current frame and that allows
us to calculate his angle of trajectory
and we can see based on that trajectory
if he was above a tile before he entered
into it and that will give us the
ability to get rid of that broken
functionality that you saw where I would
jump up and just almost teleport through
this tile and sit on top of it
so that's why we have to keep track of
this this is also great for
interpolation which is something really
useful for smooth animation but I'm not
going to talk about that in this video
anyway that is the narrow phase it's
really simple the functions are all
really really simple if you just take a
look at the source code I urge you to go
to the link in the video description and
check that out on my github page and
that's it I'm going to show you how I
added sprite animation to the game so
you can take my example and use it to
put sprite animation into your own
programs I'm going to talk about what's
new in part 5 then I'll give you a very
simple and brief refresher on how sprite
animation works when using a sprite
sheet and finally we'll take an in-depth
look at the animator class and how it
works with the players movement to
render the appropriate animations
alrighty so the first thing I want to
take a look at in part 5 is the example
program and as you can see in this
example program I no longer am working
with the little white and gray squared
now I am working with this animated
rabbit and he looks a lot better it's
starting to look a lot more like a game
that you can actually play just -
power-ups and items and stuff like that
so basically not much has changed other
than I've added an animator
class that does the sprite animation and
I've also tweaked his physics for
jumping and stuff like that a little bit
but that's pretty pretty common-sense
stuff kind of know how to do that if
you're already to this point in the
tutorial series so I'm not gonna worry
about the specific changes I made for
this video instead I'm just gonna worry
about showing you guys how the animator
class works to get this guy animated on
the screen if you do want to see what
has actually changed in the code since
part four take a look at the source code
that I've linked in the video
description at the top of each file that
has changed and for par five it's just
these three the game the display and the
main files for each file that has
changes in it I've added a bulleted list
in the comments at the top of each file
that outlines what exactly has changed
specifically in the code so you want to
find out what's changed take a look at
the source code and take a look at these
comments but in this video I'm just
gonna focus on the animator class and
how to get this dude animated on the
screen so stay tuned and I'll show you
how it's done
now let's take a brief look at how
sprite animation actually works when
you're using a sprite sheet so this here
is my sprite sheet images two PNG has
all my tiles and it has my sprite images
in it now each sprite animation is just
a compilation of these different unique
images so each image can be considered
just a square that you would cut out of
this bigger image and then put on the
screen in quick succession to give
yourself an animation so for instance
right now my player character isn't
doing anything he's just sitting still
this frame is literally being cut from
this position right here if you notice
this and this are exactly the same image
so currently he is displaying this frame
of animation if I were to move him to
the left now he's gonna stand still he's
gonna be displaying this frame right
here when he's walking it's gonna give
me an animation so I'm gonna be playing
those frames over and over again in
quick succession it's kind of hard to
tell cuz he's walking so fast but he's
basically playing when I walked to the
right he's playing this set of frames
right here he's stepping through these
four frames right here and that's gonna
give me my animation so what's happening
is on every frame that I draw to the
screen I'm going to see
which frame that my player characters
class is determining that he should show
based on his movement pattern it's going
to take that frame it's going to go into
this tile sheet image it's going to cut
that specific frame out of the tile
sheet it is then going to take that
frame and draw it to the players
location on this display canvas this
canvas element that I have in the
browser window and you're gonna see
whatever frame that is supposed to be
displayed and that's gonna give you
animation so that's basically how it
works basically you're just cutting
different images out of a bigger sprite
sheet image and you're displaying those
smaller images at the players unique
location on the screen now we're gonna
take an in-depth look at what makes the
code actually work or I guess we're just
gonna take an in-depth look at the code
because the code makes the code work so
here I'm gonna start with the frame
class now the frame class is just gonna
define a rectangular region that we are
going to cut our sprite images out of
the tile sheet with so it has an X value
of Y value within a height and that's
just going to be the source rectangle
that defines the individual image inside
of our sprite sheet so I'm gonna use one
of those frame classes to define each
rectangular region for each one of these
individual images so that's what the
frame class is gonna be for and just
bear with me as I explain all these
different classes and you'll see how
they fit together at the end of this
part of the video so don't worry about
the offset X&Y positions to see I'll
tell you about those later just keep in
mind it's just a rectangular region for
the moment now we're gonna look at the
tile set class and this used to be the
tile sheet class inside of the display
file but I moved it over to the game
file basically the functionality is
exactly the same and just renamed it and
it's location is different
basically just keeps track of the number
of columns and tile size of our rabbit
traps sprite sheet image and that's it
where animation comes in here is what
the frames erase so now we just talked
about the frames class which is down
there the frames class is just a
rectangular region with an offset
position each one of these values inside
of this frames array is just going to be
one of the rectangular regions that
corresponds to a
specific graphic for our animation so
for example this frame is where the idle
left graphic is inside of our sprite
sheet this frame is where the jump left
graphic is inside of our sprite sheet
this group of frames is going to be
where all of the individual graphics are
for the walk left animation down here we
got the walk right animation so
basically all I'm doing is defining each
rectangular region for every one of my
sprite animation components or basically
these individual images so now you know
where the individual frames are going to
be defined inside of the tileset class
now we're actually going to have to
define what those animations are so the
animation itself is going to be defined
by the object that's using it so the
animation for this rabbit or for the
player is going to live inside of the
player class so every unique animation
the idle frames the walking left and
right frames the jump frames those are
all going to be stored inside of the
player class inside of its prototype so
I'm just scrolling up to that here we
have the player prototype and inside of
it we have an object called frame sets
and inside a frame sets we have all the
different animations for the player we
have as idle left jump left move left
and then the right words motions for
those different animations so each one
of these values corresponds to a frame
inside of our tilesets frames array so
for example idle left is going to have a
value of 0 in it and 0 is going to be
the frame index or the index inside of
our frames array where the rectangular
region is defined to cut the image out
of the sprite sheet for the idle left
animation and that's just going to be
here so this is index 0 inside of our
frames array it's idle left and that's
what we're going to use for the idle
left animation of our player and that's
why that value is going to be a 0 so as
you can see each one of these values
just corresponds to a different frame
inside of the frames array and what a
frame is it's just a rectangular region
that we use to cut out our sprite sheet
images from the sprite sheet so how do
we actually animate these that's gonna
be our next class that we look at and
that's going to be the animator class so
I'm gonna scroll up to the animator
class and I'm gonna take a look at what
this guy does so here's the animator
class it's a frame rate dependent
animation class so what that means is
the rate of frames that you see for each
animation is gonna be totally dependent
on the game engines frame rate so if you
don't want that kind of functionality
this probably isn't for you but if
you're just gonna run your game
consistently at 30 frames per second
across all devices this is probably what
you want to do and for html5 games
that's a pretty good bet so this will
probably work for you so I defined a
couple different values in here I have
count delay frame set frame set is going
to be those different frame sets are
those different animation arrays that I
define inside the player so for example
frame set could be I'm gonna scroll down
here it could be any one of these
animations
it could be idle left it could be this
array right here it could be move left
which is that array right there it could
be any one of those and basically it's
just gonna use that information and loop
through it when it does my animation so
went too far here we go so the frame set
is just gonna be one of those arrays
with those values and those values of
course correspond to our different
frames that we used to cut the animation
image out of the spritesheet frame index
is just gonna be where we are or where
the playhead is so to speak inside of
that frame set array frame value is
going to be the value of whatever index
were in inside of our frame set so for
idle left remember that was value 0 the
value was 0 so for that particular
animation it would be at index 0 inside
the frame set and the value would also
be 0 for the idle left image and then we
have mode mode right now for this
example there are only two modes we have
pause and we have Lu
now pause and loop are just gonna be the
two types of playback that we want our
animations to do so pretty simply I'm
gonna just explain that as we go I'm
gonna come down to the loop function all
it does is it just changes the playhead
position every so many frames that pass
in our game loop so count is gonna
increase one time on every cycle of our
game loop until it reaches the delay
that we specify so for the walking left
and right animations I've defined a
delay of five inside of the player class
so every five frames of our game loops
animation or cycle we are going to run
the code inside of this while loop so
count we're just going to decrease that
by delay and that makes us wait again
frame index this is where we set the
frame index or the playhead inside of
our animation basically this we're just
gonna say is the frame index currently
less than the frame set that length so
let's take a visual look at what's going
on here inside of our rabbit trap PNG so
let's say the frame set that we're going
to use has values that correspond to the
walking right animation which is going
to be these four frames right here so
frame index at zero is going to yield a
frame value of this image right here at
frame index of one I'm going to move
over one it's gonna be a value that
corresponds to this image right here
when I move it over again it's gonna
correspond to this image right here so
basically what the code inside of the
loop function is doing is it's just
increasing my frame index by one until
it reaches the end of the frame set and
when it reaches the end of the frame set
the next time it goes to increase
instead it just sets it back to zero so
inside of my loop function all that
we're gonna do is just say set the frame
index equal to the frame index plus one
if it's not yet past the end of our
frame set length and if it is past the
end of the frame set length just set its
zero
to restart the animation loop over again
then finally what we do is we get the
frame value that's just gonna be the
value that corresponds to the specific
rectangular region that we store in the
tile sets frames array that corresponds
to the image that we're going to be
cutting out of the sprite sheet so the
frame value is just going to be set to
whatever our frame set array is and
we're gonna hand in the index of the the
playhead so whatever frame index is
that's gonna give us the value inside of
our frame set that we're currently at in
the animations loop cycle all right so
that was a mouthful hopefully I'm
explaining everything quite well I think
the next place we want to go is probably
the render function but first I want to
just touch on this functionality here
the change frame set function inside of
the animator class and basically what
this does is it just changes what frames
that we're using so whenever I press
left on the keyboard I'm gonna call
change frame set it's just gonna change
the frame set to the left animation
which is that array inside of the player
class that defines which frame sees for
the left animation when I press write
it's gonna call change frame set I'm
gonna hand in the players right movement
animation if I jump to the left
I'm gonna call change frame set I'm
gonna hand in the left animation you
kind of get what I'm saying here then
the only other function in here is gonna
be the animate function it just checks
to see which mode were in loop or pause
pause is going to be for no animation so
pause is going to be called on the idle
animation so idle right and idle left
pause is going to be the play method
that we use for the walking animations
we're going to be using the loop method
because we want to keep animating that
cycle of frames over and over and over
again and basically this is just called
on every frame and it just calls the
corresponding method it's pretty simple
so now that we know how we're animating
our frames let's actually take a look at
the render function which lives inside
of the main file and we're gonna take a
look at how we actually use that frame
information to cut our image out of the
sprite she is self so the first thing we
do we're actually going to have to jump
to another section the code real quick
because I'm using
assets manager to load my tileset image
so real quick I'm just gonna jump up
here check out the assets manager class
all it is is an image and I'm gonna load
in an image with our rabbit trap dot PNG
image inside of it so really all that
we're doing here is just using the
assets manager to load our tile sheet
really simple so that's all that is
don't worry about it too much you could
write your own code you don't need an
assets manager all you need is to load
up the tile sheet image to use it for
drawing from that tile sheet image so
here we go here's where we get the frame
value so frame we're gonna get the frame
remember it's just that rectangular
region but we're going to get to it
through all those classes I just talked
about so the animation class is going to
give us a pointer to a frame value which
lives inside of the frame array inside
of the tile set class and then the tile
set class is going to be using the frame
class to define its rectangular regions
to cut images out of the tile sheet
image so how we get the frame is we just
get the frames array from our games tile
set then we go ahead and we hand in the
players current frame value which is
kept up to date on every cycle of our
game loop inside of the update function
we're going to be calling player dot
update animation and that's going to
update our frame value inside of the
loop function most likely of our
animator class so draw object is going
to take all this information and put it
together to give us the appropriate
image that we need to see to make our
animation work on the screen so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna hand in
our source tile sheet image then we're
gonna hand in the actual source frames
X&Y position to cut from then this is
gonna look a little complex but it's
really not we're gonna hand in the
players X location and Y location and
we're just gonna add basically an offset
where we want the frame to show up and
be drawn to the screen so
right now the players frame is slightly
offset from the players relocation and
the reason I want that to happen is so
when I stand on the edge of a tile
I actually fall through and if you look
his ears on the the frame are actually
kind of moving through the tile or if I
go over here the image itself is
actually overlapping the tile I don't
want it to be pixel perfect like that I
want it to be functional I want the
player to have fun I don't care about
pixel perfect collision as much as I do
the player having fun so this code
basically what it does is it just
repositions the frame a little bit to
Center it on the players position so we
can more easily move him around the
screen without that pixel perfect
collision that makes his hitbox seem a
lot larger than it needs to be so all
this does is it gets his exposition it
adds the center or it gets the center of
where I want to draw that frame on top
of the player by just getting half of
his with subtracting half of the frame
source frames with and then it just adds
the frames offset X position if I don't
add that offset X position and remember
I was talking about that for the frame
class but come back into the frame class
all the way at the bottom here we
defined the offset X and offset Y and
then when we actually instantiate each
frame we're gonna add negative 2 which
is the going offset Y position for this
player if I don't add negative 2 this is
what happens I just set it to 0 I saved
I'm gonna come back in here as you can
see now that was a y offset he's now 2
pixels deep into the ground and that
does not look quite right so that's why
I have that offset position all it does
is add a slight offset when I draw the
frame to the screen to make him appear
in the appropriate location so that's it
that's all that does you don't need this
stuff like I said I am using a frame
based approach you could easily use a
tile based approach where you have all
your graphics inside of one big grid
kind of like the tiles are instead of
having them all close together and
cutting them out specifically the reason
I do this is because if I were to add
let's say my rabbit has a sword and the
sword comes out
here now my sprite is gonna be different
and it's not necessarily going to fit
uniformly into a box or into a grid row
and column cell with all the other
sprites so I do it this way because
sprites change they change in size they
vary in size depending on what animation
you're doing so this is just much more
flexible for me so now let's get back
into the rendering function went off on
a little rant there so basically all the
draw object function does of the display
class is just draw from the tile set
from the frames X&Y position and it
draws to the screen whatever frame is
currently in the animation in the
players and animation draws that frame
to the screen at a slight offset
position then we call display dot render
and that draws everything to the screen
including the tiles and whatever frame
of animation our players in alright so
now let me just quickly see if I
actually missed anything here I think I
went over everything how everything
works let me take a look inside of the
player class itself and actually see how
we're doing the players animation how
we're actually deciding which frames to
display in which frame sets to use this
is going to be done inside of the update
animation function so update anime
animation is going to be called on every
cycle of our game loop and it's
basically just gonna check to see what
direction the player is facing and it's
gonna choose an animation based on that
so the very first if statement inside of
update animation is going to be is the
player moving up which means is the
player jumping up so if I press up on
the keyboard the player is going to move
up and if you look closely you can see
that the up animation or the up frame is
played briefly while he's moving up
while he's moving down it switches back
to idle left so if he is moving up and
if his direction which is determined
just by which direction he's facing so
when I press the left key his Direction
is going to be negative one when I press
the right key Direction is going to be
positive one so if his Direction is
negative one so he's facing left I'm
going to change his animation frame set
to John
left if that's not the case and he's
facing the right I'm gonna change his
animation frame set while he's jumping
to jump right I'm gonna do that in the
pause position now for these other ones
basically is he moving to the left if he
is and his velocity is a certain amount
then we're going to play the move left
animation if the velocity is not a
certain amount or less than that
basically if he's basically stopped and
his velocity is very small we're gonna
play idle left instead now this is cool
because what this functionality allows
us to do is it allows us to have our
player gradually stop walking even
though we're not pressing the wall key
anymore so if I were to come in here and
change this code to let's say this is
the left walking animation what does
this move left let's change this to two
negative two I saved I'm gonna come up
here refresh my screen now let's see
what happens for the walk animation
because I have to be moving at to a
velocity of two to the left the Move
animation doesn't actually run unless I
hit that two pixels of movement velocity
per frame so what this allows me to do
is it allows me to create an effect
where I gradually walk to a stop instead
of just halting to a stop really hard
like that so a better a better kind of
example would be if I used one instead
and I refresh the screen up here let's
see what that looks like now I start
walking right away because I hit a
velocity of 1 to the left really quick
but as soon as I stop I go into the idle
animation and that's not really good
because it looks like I'm sliding too
much or maybe you do prefer that and
that's the great thing about this code
you can just do whatever you want I kind
of like it where I'm just gonna
gradually stop walking so I'm completely
stopped I don't prefer to just
automatically stop and slide on my feet
like that so what I've done is I've just
a very small value for the velocity
check and if he is moving slower than
naked
point one pixels to the left then he's
going to idle and if not he's going to
continue walking until he just comes
that gradual stop like that so that's
pretty cool so basically the update
animation function is fired on every
frame after you do collision detection
with the player in the world and it just
determines what way he's moving and
depending on what direction he's moving
it runs a certain animation now this is
actually really important it's more
important than you think
not necessarily for the player because
you can have fine control over the
player but for non player characters who
move on their own you have to determine
their animation based on how they're
moving because you don't control them
you can't say play the run animation
when I press the Run key because you're
not pressing a key for a non-player
character for those non player
characters you have to keep track of
what direction they're moving how
they're moving and based on that you
have to set their animations so that's
what this code does it just automates
the process of setting the animation it
doesn't rely on key presses or user
input it just sets the animation
depending on what direction he's moving
before I go any further with this series
I want to address something called
tunneling it presents major problems for
any physics engine and tower based
engines are no exception tunneling is
sure to affect you particularly if you
are writing your own physics engine so
stay tuned while I talk about how to
overcome this pesky glitch alright so
let's take a look at what tunneling
actually looks like so this is the part
5 example program and I haven't changed
any of the code since part 5 but I just
want to show you this one glitch that
happens underneath this t-shaped
structure of tiles when I am running
into this tile from the right so I'm
pressing down on the Left key and I jump
I actually pass into the tile now I can
actually jump down below the tiles and
walk around because of the nature of my
tile based collision code but obviously
you don't want that to happen this
actually isn't a problem with the
collision code itself this is just the
problem with tunneling and it seems to
happen just in this one scenario so in
order to show you guys better what's
actually happening first I'm gonna
explain what tunneling is just using my
mouse pointer is an example and then I'm
gonna show you
slow motion when I slow this game down
I'm gonna show you what's actually
happening with the player and whitening
is happening in this particular instance
so tunneling is when the object moves
too far in one frame to actually collide
with the collision shape so let's say
that this tile is gonna be my collision
shape and the mouse pointer is going to
be my object so this is frame 1 on frame
1 my object is right here where the
mouse pointer is and on frame 2 I'm
going to move my object a little bit to
the left so this is frame 1 this is
frame to my object has moved about 16
pixels to the left now this is ok
because I'm not moving more than one
tile space I'm actually going to be over
top of this tile space is gonna detect
that I'm colliding with it it's gonna
move the mouse out of the collision and
put it back into an empty tile space
that's how it should work
tunneling happens when the mouse moves
much farther than one tile space or 16
pixels in this case over the course of
one frame so if this is frame 1 and I
move in frame 2 all the way to here
what's happening is I'm jumping right
from here all the way to here and I'm
never detecting a collision with that
tile because I'm never landing in it so
tunneling is basically just moving a
player object or any object too quickly
to detect collision with a stationary
collision object so now that you kind of
understand what tunneling is let me slow
this down and show you in action what
the tunneling looks like with the player
character so I'm gonna save my code I'm
gonna set the frame rate to 1 frame per
second it's gonna slow things down a lot
and I'm gonna refresh now as you can see
things are really really slow so I'm
gonna run over here into the corner and
it's gonna take a while so just bear
with me but I'm gonna show you this
glitch in slow motion as I think it
should be I don't want to go any slower
than this or it would take forever
so here I am I'm standing next to the
tile I'm gonna press up and I'm just
gonna jump straight up so I jumped up
and immediately this tile up here
resolves collision in throws me
right back down below it but if I jump
up while I'm pressing the left key I
jump up and I move slightly to the left
now that's when the tunnelling occurs so
the tunneling isn't actually happening
on this tile right here it's actually
it's kind of a special case but I'll
show you why so I'm gonna run back out
here and I'm just gonna jump up the
tunneling is actually happening when I
jump because the player character is
moving about 20 pixels upwards as soon
as I start jumping and you'll be able to
see that when I jump here in a moment so
I could actually get this thing to
comply it's just moving so slowly all
right so I'm gonna jump and just take
note of where this player actually moves
to when I jump so this is the top of the
player right here this would be 16
pixels from the ground right here when I
press the jump key immediately my player
is above that 16 pixels his feet were
about right here and he clearly moves
more than 16 pixels which is our tile
space so if he can potentially move past
one full tile space without stopping in
it he can tunnel because tunneling is
basically when on frame 1 were out of
collision on frame 2 we jump over a
collision object and never touch it so
what's happening here is when he jumps
imagine what happens if he were standing
right here he's gonna jump up on the
first frame his the top of his hitbox is
actually gonna be over top of this tile
and the bottom of his hitbox is gonna be
inside of this tile so what's happening
is when he jumps and he's standing here
he's gonna jump up he's not even gonna
have a chance to cry with this tile
because the top two corners I'm checking
on his hitbox are over top of this tile
even the only reason collision happens
on this tile is because his two bottom
feet where his two bottom corners are
inside of this tile and he can still
technically move to the left while he's
in this tile because collision is only
gonna happen in this tile with the
bottom side of the tile and it does when
I'm out standing
neat this tile it does do collision but
just on the bottom side I can still move
to the left so when I jump up underneath
this tile I'm gonna jump I'm gonna hit
my head on the bottom and it's gonna
send me right back down again
but remember I'm jumping 20 pixels high
so what's gonna happen is just my feet
are gonna collide with this when I jump
I'm actually gonna move up here then
it's gonna place me back down there and
I can still move over to the left so
when I jump up and press left I'm
actually going to be up here and I'm
gonna fall back down into this tile on
the wrong side of the collision boundary
so that's what tunneling is and there's
a really easy way to fix it if I come in
here and I set this back to let's see 30
frames a second that ought to do see
what that looks like 30 frames a second
things are back to normal what I'm
actually gonna do is I'm gonna come out
here and I'm gonna change the speed at
which he jumps and that's actually gonna
fix everything so if I can find where
that is oh it's actually in the game
object here see jump I'm actually
setting jump whenever he jumps I call
this function and it moves him 20 pixels
up it sets his Y velocity a negative 20
pixels so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
set it to negative 15 pixels and that's
gonna prevent him from ever moving more
than one tile space and actually I'm
gonna set this back to one frame so you
guys can see that in action as well
let's go back to one frame per second
refresh and now we're gonna zoom in and
take a closer look at this guy jumping
so this is what 16 pixels looks like
when he jumps as you can see his bottom
feet are no longer way up here on that
first frame on that first frame there
down here so he'll still end up
colliding with this tile right here so
when I moved back into collision I'm
gonna speed things up for this set it
back to 30 frames a second save come
over here refresh my page and now
tunneling can no longer happen so
collision is going to happen as I expect
it to so that is the problem
I guess I kind of showed you how to fix
it in the first part but I'll go into
more detail on how to fix it in the next
part okay so we just looked at part
fives
example program where we had this glitch
where actually I fixed it but very fresh
we had this glitch I'm gonna leave that
in actually so if you ever check out
part 5 that glitch is gonna be left in
there but now I want to show you a
better way to fix it and this is a sneak
peak if you will at part 6 where I
actually did fix his problem so here's
the same exact tile structure same
scenario in par 6 without the glitch now
how I did this was I basically just
clamped his movement velocity to never
exceed 16 pixels or one tile space now
if you just reduce the amount of
velocity that he jumps at it can cause
problems so for instance here I'm gonna
take a look at part five again here's
part five I can jump up above this tile
if I have a Y velocity of negative
twenty pixels per frame when I jump so
obviously if I reduce this to 15 I save
it's gonna read it's gonna eliminate the
possibility of tunneling that's great
but now I can't jump up on my platforms
anymore so how do I fix this well the
way to fix it is to go ahead and change
your gravity and friction at least
that's one way to fix it so I'm gonna
save that so it's back the way it was
I'm gonna come over here and I'm gonna
take a look at the code excuse me let's
take a look at the code inside of part 6
so in part 6 I'm still using a velocity
of negative 15 when I jump the only
difference is now I'm clamping my
movement velocity when I update the
players position so basically to do that
I'm just saying if the absolute value of
the player's X velocity or Y velocity is
greater than some max velocity and
that's gonna be 16 or 15 basically our
tile size or maybe one less just to be
safe if it's greater than that then
we're gonna set our velocity to the max
velocity and actually this code is wrong
because I don't want to change the sign
of my
velocity I just want to change the
amount of my velocity so but you get the
idea part six of stone development
basically what you want to do is you
want to clamp your movement speed and to
get the same jump height with the
different Y velocity what you do is you
just reduce gravity and friction so here
is what a jump looks like in part five
as you can see he jumps a lot faster
it's kind of almost too quick so this is
almost an improvement for visuals as
well and this is part six where I've
kind of changed it up so he can have a
clamp velocity and he just moves a
little more smoothly if you look at it
it's a little more smooth here's part
five again jumps really far really fast
it's a little bit too quick part six a
little more smooth hopefully you can
pick that up with my video recorder here
because sometimes it doesn't quite match
the frame rate of the game when it's
recording so basically what you want to
do to fix tunneling is you want to clamp
your jump speed so the amount of
velocity that you apply to a jump and
that's gonna be where a lot of your
velocity comes into play high velocities
when you're jumping that's gonna be a
thing you want to clamp it to an amount
that's less than one tile space then in
order to get the height of the jump that
you want you're gonna have to reduce
gravity and friction so for me I came in
when I define the world object what I do
is I just have gravity and friction
defined here so for example friction if
I change the value of friction to say
0.9 0.99 that's gonna be really low
friction so if I come over here and
refresh now I'm gonna have really really
low friction and as you can see I'm just
moving really fast all over the place
jump really far really fast cuz there's
no friction so I don't want that but
that's basically how you fix tunneling
you just basically have to clamp your
velocity to a certain speed and to get a
the jump height that you want you just
mess with friction and grab
and that's gonna do it for tunneling I'm
going to show you how to create level
data files using JSON how to load level
data and use it to populate the game
world and finally how to trigger
subsequent level loads by colliding with
doors let's take a look at what has
changed since part 5 in part 5 and a
half so this is part 6 and everything is
basically the same I did make quite a
few changes but most of those changes
pertain to loading different levels so
when I jump up into this area here and
walk off the side of the screen it's
actually going to load a different level
as you just saw so how this is working
is I have a little door hit region just
off the right of the screen here and
it's just a rectangular box and when the
player characters center point hits that
box it loads the level and places the
player in whatever location he needs to
be to start this level out when walking
through that door from the other level
so basically in parsecs I just have a
couple different levels and I've defined
a couple different types of doors
they're all just rectangles you just saw
two small rectangular doors this area on
the bottom of this level is one big
rectangular door so I can jump up
through it at any point in this
rectangle so this system works great for
any size door doesn't just have to be
one tile it can be any size rectangle
that you define so that's basically part
six so now that you know what the
example program is about let's get into
how this works before we get into the
JavaScript code let's actually take a
look at the different level files so
this would be level 0 0 or I call it
zone 0 0 so the file to load this level
that you see on the screen is this file
right here zone 0 0 and basically it's
just a couple of different JSON
structures so I have a doors array and
inside of that I just have the doors
that are contained in this level so for
this level level 0 0 or zone 0 0 I have
one door just to the right of this tile
the door would be right here off the
level that you see on the screen and
this JSON here defines an array of doors
and this object inside of it will be
that door object that resides right over
here so that's my doors array now
here I have some information about the
maps each map has 12 columns and nine
rows I did not format this so you could
actually see it in kind of a 2d row and
column format I just have it in one big
long array but if I were to line this up
so each row had 12 columns in it you
would see that the maps are 12 columns
by 9 rows but this is my graphics map so
these are all my graphic style values
this is my collision map so these are
all the collision values for the tiles
and then finally I have ID and that's
just gonna be the level ID so like I
said this is zone 0 0 so when I load
zone 0 0 this just tells my world object
that it's zone ID 0 0 so now let's take
a look at zone 2 and we'll just take a
look at zone twos code really quick just
so you get it in your head that this is
what the the format is so here's my
doors array zone 2 has two doors there's
a door right here to go back into zone 0
or actually zone 1 excuse me
as I started labeling a zero but this is
zone 1 and it leads back into zone 0 0
there's a door right off the left side
of the screen here and it goes into zone
0 2 with a door right over here
on the far right side of the screen so
inside of my doors aright I have defined
two door objects and then same as before
I have my columns and rows and my two
maps and the ID that just indicates what
zone this is so if you know how to write
JavaScript you know how to write JSON
for the most part it's really easy and
it's a really great natural fit for
writing information that you're gonna
load into your JavaScript game because
it's so similar to JavaScript already
and you have the built in json dot parse
method to parse this information into
useable javascript objects so now that
you know how to write the level data
let's get on to the next part of the
video ok so now that we know how to
define our level data we need to figure
out a way to load it and the best way to
load it is with xml httprequest so
inside of my main J's file I have a
class called assets manager and it
basically just has
function called request JSON inside of
it so in order to load my JSON file I'm
gonna call this request JSON function
I'm gonna pass in the URL of the file to
load so basically I'm just if I want to
load zone zero zero I'm gonna pass in
the string zone zero zero JSON and I'm
gonna provide a callback function but
I'll get to the callback function later
so first thing I'm gonna do is create an
XML HTTP request I'm going to give it an
event listener for the load event and
I'm gonna have an event handler for wind
loads which is just gonna call my
callback and hand in the parsed JSON
string from my JSON file so I'm gonna
send off my request to the server it's
gonna process it it's gonna hand me back
the file content remember that file was
zone zero zero JSON it's literally gonna
hand back this stuff in response text or
just text format and I'm going to take
that response text or the content my
JSON file I'm gonna use JSON to parse to
turn it into a JavaScript object and I'm
gonna call the callback so that's the
request JSON file that we're gonna use
to actually load our data so now let's
take a look at where we first load up a
level when we first start the game and
that's gonna happen all the way at the
bottom of the main J's file in the
initial of the initialization section so
this is where we're using the request
JSON file to load up our very first
level so when I click refresh my code is
going to run in main jas and this right
here is going to be responsible for
loading up zone zero zero which is on
the screen right here so let's just take
a look at what we're handing it calling
assets manager dot request JSON zone
prefix that's just gonna be the string
zone for the first part of our URL game
dot world does zone ID when I first
instantiate game it creates an object
called world so game dot world is a
world object and that has a default
value in it of zero zero for world zero
zero or zone zero zero so that's where
we're gonna get the zero zero from this
is going to be zero zero and zone suffix
is
just gonna be dot JSON so I have the
zone prefix of zone plus the game dot
world dot zone ID which is 0 0 plus zone
suffix which is going to be dot JSON so
I'm gonna hand in that URL to request
JSON it's gonna send a request to the
server when the server returns the JSON
data inside of zone 0 0 and text format
I'm gonna parse it into a Jace or a
JavaScript object and then I'm going to
hand that JavaScript object into my
callback function which is just gonna be
defined here I've defined it in arrow
function format so this is my callback
function and remember that I passed in
JSON that parse requests that response
text so that's gonna be the JavaScript
objects that I created from my zone file
and I'm gonna hand that into game dot
world dot set up so let's go ahead and
take a look real quick a game dot world
I set up and also where we create the
very first default value for zone ID so
you see if I can find where I'm at here
I'm inside of the game file and this is
the game dot world dot prototype so
let's go up a little bit more game that
world this is where we define game dot
world let me real quick just take a look
at the default value for zone ID so
remember the default value for zone ID
we're gonna use that right here when
we're loading our first level so that's
just going to be defined right here
right now the default value is 0 0 so
when i refresh the page the first level
loads is 0 0 if I change that to say 0 1
and save it and refresh the page keep an
eye on the level map it's gonna load up
world 0 1 if I change it again
let's go world 0 to save we're gonna
load up and it's gonna immediately well
it dropped us in world 2 but we fell
down into world 3 so basically this sets
our default level to load initially when
we boot up the game so that's where we
define that but now we're going to take
a look at
game dot world that set up where we
actually put all the information from
our zone file into our game dot world
object which we use on every frame of
animation to do stuff with our games so
down here is the setup function this is
game dot world uh setup and it takes one
parameter which is the zone which we
just parsed into a Jake JavaScript
object from our zone zero zero JSON file
so basically all we do is copy over all
the values from our newly created zone
object and we copy those values into our
world object pretty simple the only one
we don't copy directly is the doors
array and the reason for that is because
I want to use a door object that I
define I'll talk about that in the next
part but we do loop through all the
doors in the zones doors array and we
just create a new door from the doors
that we loop through so inside of this
zone file we'd have an array called
doors every object inside we get and we
convert this data into a game door
object so this class here we're just
gonna create a door object from the door
data inside of our zone doors array so
whatever door we loop over in that doors
are right gonna be converted into a game
door class and that's what we're gonna
use for our actual game logic and game
physics when we collide with the doors
and stuff now we finally know how we're
setting up the very first initial level
I'm getting out of breath here I'm
talking so much but now we need to know
one more thing and that's how to
actually go ahead and load a level on
the fly when we when we walk into a door
so where we do that is inside of the
update function for the game so on every
cycle of our game engine on every game
loop so to speak we're going to call
this function from inside of main and
this is the update function so the first
thing we do is get some user input then
we call game update game to update cakes
it takes care of moving the player takes
care of all the world collision and
inside of the game that update function
is the world dot update function so
let's go ahead and take a look at world
dot update real quick already inside a
world game dot world dot prototype so
this is the game dot world that update
function which is called inside of the
game dot update function which we're
calling right here so basically this
function is going to call this function
so first thing we do is update the
players position we collide the player
with the world this refers to game dot
world so we're gonna Clyde the player
with the world so all the tiles then
we're gonna come down here and we're
gonna loop through all the doors in the
world in the current region or zone of
the world we're going to get each door
and we're gonna test for collision with
the door and it's just basic rectangular
collision I'll cover it in the next part
of the video basically if we do collide
with the door so if the player actually
collides with the door we're going to
set this dot door or gained world door
equal to that door that we just collided
with so normally this door is undefined
so out here in our update function which
is called on every frame we're going to
test to see if game that world door is
not equal to undefined and the only time
it's not equal to undefined is when for
a split second we actually walk into it
and then this if statement returns true
and we go ahead and load the world that
was specified by whatever door we
collided with so let's just go through
this real quick and see what happens the
first thing that happens when I run into
a door so if I run into a door the first
thing that happens is I stop the engine
I then make a request with requests JSON
to whatever zone that door
brings you to so if I come up here into
my zone 0 0 JSON we're in zone 0 0 the
destination zone for this specific door
located at an X of 192 which is about
there and a Y of 64 which is about there
has a width and height of 16 so
right off the right of the screen here
is a box that's about 16 by 16 pixels
and when I collide with it it's gonna
load zone 0 1 and it's gonna put the
player at Destination X of 0 and
negative 1 just means we're not going to
use destination wise so the players why
destination remains the same but I'll
get into the next part so basically
we're gonna request the destination zone
specified by that door so this door here
that we're about to walk in right to the
right the player will tell us to go to
world or zone 0 1 so when I walk into it
this code loads up zone 0 1 pretty
simple the same thing that we did for
the initial level load we're just doing
again right here even have the same
arrow function with the zone parameter
specified inside then inside of our
callback after request JSON requests the
level data the server gives it back to
us in text format it parses that into a
JSON object called zone and hands it
back to us we're just gonna call game
dot world dot setup and it's gonna get
all the information out of the level
file and put it on the screen basically
so there is one difference this time
however because now we're going to have
to use some information from a specific
door so let me go back inside the game
dot world dot setup function real quick
I'm gonna scroll up to it right here
game dot world I set up and we check for
the case that we are colliding with the
door because remember when we enter into
collision with the door we set the
worlds this dot door property equal to
the door so when we call setup this dot
door is actually going to be equal to
whatever door we just caught it with so
if I come over here and clad with the
door that's right over here it's going
to be equal to that door that I just
caught it with and it's basically it's
just going to set the player's X&Y
center position to whatever the doors
destination x and y values were and
that's it really simple everything else
works the same as the initial level
load the only difference is when you
walk into a specific door you reposition
the player according to that doors
destination X and destination y so stay
tuned for the next part where I'm gonna
talk about the door class specifically
the collision and all that kind of good
stuff now I want to take a look at what
a door actually is so if i zoom in here
I'm gonna look at what a door is inside
of my zone zero zero dot JSON file I've
got an X position in a Y position a
width and a height so basically my door
is just a rectangular region on the
screen somewhere that the player object
can collide with then I also have a
destination zone that's gonna be where
the player is going to go what level I'm
gonna load if the player hits the door
and I have a destination X and a
destination Y for the player as well so
this is where I'm gonna put the player
in the newly loaded zone when it loads
if I have a negative one that just means
destination wide does not get used and
the players Y position remains the same
same thing for X if I have a negative
one the destination X position isn't
going to be used
players x position is gonna remain the
same so we can see this functionality
over here if I fall into this world I'm
not being repositioned
on the y axis or on the x axis rather
because I don't need to be I just want
to fall right through and naturally have
my player end up where he has to be
based on where he was in the previous
level I don't want to jump through this
floor door right here and end up at the
very start of the door over here in the
next level if I jump through over here
like if I jump through right here I
don't want to come out in this world
right here because it just wouldn't look
right so that's the only reason I have a
negative one there but anyway let's look
at the door class the game world door
class and actually see what that looks
like in the collision code that I'm
using to have the player in the door
actually collide so I could find that
wherever that is a scroll Scroll scroll
hopefully I'll come across it soon ah
this is it right here so it's a really
simple object gonna correct that small
formatting
they're really tiny object basically is
the same exact thing as this right here
it just has a prototype defined with the
collide object function inside of it so
this is the door class and I'm gonna
call object on it object all it is is a
rectangle class that has some functions
for helping me determine the sides of a
rectangle so it has functions like get
left to get right get top get bottom
just defining a rectangle here
inheriting from the object class then
I'm gonna set the destination XY and
zone to whatever those are from the door
object that we hand in and that's just
going to be whatever is defined inside
of the zone file then inside of the
prototype I have a function called
collide object and that's just gonna
test to see if the object's center
points are inside of the rectangular
region of the door so this code right
here just test to see if the player is
not colliding with the door if he's not
then I'm gonna return false and that
means we didn't have a collision with
the door if any of this is true or
actually if any of this is false then we
know that we have collided with door and
in that case we're gonna return true so
where do we actually use this that's
gonna be inside of the world update
functions so if I come down here to
world world dot updates right here there
we go
okay so inside a world that update I
have all the doors to find inside of my
world doors array I'm gonna loop through
every door in that array I'm gonna get
each individual door I'm gonna test to
see if the door is colliding with the
player object and if it is I'm just
gonna set the world's door property
equal to that door and then just like in
the last part we're gonna go into the
update function for our main game loop
game loop and inside of that we're gonna
have an if statement that just checks to
see is game world door defined and the
only time it's the
find is right after we collide with the
door so we're gonna stop the engine
we're gonna load the level defined by
the door by the doors destination zone
more specifically we're gonna setup that
zone in game dot world dot set up and
we're gonna restart our engine now
inside a setup I know I'm recapping
stuff that I just talked about but
inside a setup we have this is the
inside of the setup function we have an
if statement just checks to see is this
dot door or game dot world door defined
is it not undefined if it's defined and
we have a door in there we're going to
set the players x and y coordinates
equal to whatever those were defined as
by the door object and if it's not equal
to negative one then we know we can set
it up if it is equal to negative one we
just leave it alone so that's like in
this case here where I'm not changing
the players x position so for both of
these doors this door up here and this
door down here for each level
respectively the destination X position
for that door is going to be set to
negative one because I only want to
change the player characters Y position
this way I don't have him jump through
here and start out over here on this
door so that's basically that's how I
define my door objects and that's how to
load levels with doors I'm going to show
you how I define the carrot and grass
objects in the level data file their
respective classes and the basic
collision detection used to collide with
the carrot objects the first thing I'm
going to talk about is what this example
program is all about and where the
carrot and grass objects are defined
because since the last installment of
this series I have since added carrot
objects and grass objects you can see
that I'm running into the carrot objects
and when I collide with their hitbox I
collect the carrot of a carrot counter
at the top left of the screen and then
down here I have some grass objects and
all the grass objects are are just
objects with an x and y position and
they have an animator inside of them
they extend the animator class and it
just updates the image on every frame of
the grass to give the impression that
the grass is actually swaying back and
forth so just some basic objects that
and if I come over here and take a look
at the zone file you can see that this
is my level data file and I have an
array for carats and I have an array for
grass and basically they're just little
arrays inside of here
that define an x tile position in a wide
tile position so if I come over here to
my map and i refresh this carrot is
gonna be at position 1 comma 2 so the X
tile is gonna start at 0 and go to 1
because this right here is 1 2 so X tile
1 white I love to so if I count from 0 I
get 0 1 on my X tile axis and for the
wide tile axis I have 0 1 2 so I know
that from this map I want to carry it at
position 1 2 and that's that carrot same
thing for the grass my first grass tile
is at x position 2 y position 7 and
that's going to be this grass object
right here so pretty simple so when I
load my level up I'm gonna actually have
to loop through these arrays here get
the x and y tile positions from them and
then create an object from that X&Y tile
position and if I am looping through the
carrots array I'll create a carrots
object if I'm looping through the grass
array I'll create a grass object so
let's go in and check out the setup
function of the game dot world object
the setup function just runs but come
over here and refresh my screen the
setup function runs right after the
level data is loaded so right after I
load this level data and I get access to
it with json.parse I then called the
setup function I pass in the JSON object
that I just parsed after I've loaded
that level data from JSON and I go ahead
and I set up all of the game objects and
the graphics and collision map and
everything for this level and then I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm going to loop
through the zones carrots array and the
the zones grass array and basically
those are literally just going to be
these two arrays right here so I'm gonna
loop through them and I'm gonna create a
new carrot and a new grass object for
every instance of one of those
little X&Y tile arrays that I come
across inside of the zone file so what
that looks like
is I'm just going to use a for loop I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm gonna loop
through all the karat objects inside of
my zones carats array which is just the
little tiny X&Y tile arrays I'm gonna
create a carat object they're not an
object but a variable to store that X&Y
position from the zone carrots array
then I'm going to store a new game
carrot inside of my games actual carrots
array that I'm gonna use on every frame
of the animation inside of my game
cycles on my game loop so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna feed it in x position in
pixels not in tile space so I'm gonna
take the X tile position of the carrot
which is located at position 0 inside of
that array that we loaded from the level
data and I'm gonna multiply it by the
tile set tile height which is 16 pixels
plus 5 is just gonna give me an offset
so if I were to come out here and make
this plus 0 and save I come over here
what's gonna happen is I'm no I'm gonna
I'm not gonna have an offset of 5 pixels
anymore so you can see they're kind of
offset to the left by 5 I come back in
here and I undo that the Z ctrl Z Save
come back over here and refresh now all
my carrots are in the right position
pretty much I do the same thing with the
grass basically I just loop through all
the grass in the level data file and I
create a new instance a new grass object
and I just position it based on the X&Y
tile value stored in my level data so
that's it next I'm going to take a look
at the actual classes that we use to
make the grass and carrot objects now
we're gonna take a look at the grass in
the carrot classes respectively so first
I'm going to start out with a grass
class and all it is is really simply an
animator object it inherits from
animator this way I can animate the
frames and it also has an X and y
position if you look at a grass object
which is just this right down here
obviously all it does is sit in a
location
so that's gonna be my X and y position
and it is animated so it's gonna happen
hair from the animator now the animator
class is the same class that I use to
animate the rabbit it can be reused for
all different kinds of game objects to
give them an animation so really simply
the grass class just has an animation
and a position and the carrot class kind
of does too but it also has a lot more
so let's go up and take a look at the
carrot class and see what makes it move
and how we collide with it with the
player object so here's the carrot class
and it inherits from the object class
the game the object class as well as the
animator class so the animator class
just gives it the animation the object
class is what's gonna give it its X&Y
position as well as it's within its
height and in addition to those things
it also gets the collide object function
which is going to be responsible for
allowing us to collide with a carrot and
actually collect it so that's important
to note then some cool features about
the carrot we have the base X Y and
position X Y values so base X and base Y
are just referring to the center
position that the carrot is rotating
around or making that figure-eight
around so that's gonna be the base X and
base Y position the carrot does still
have an x and y position that's gonna be
where it's actually drawn to the base X
and base Y are going to be just the
point that it rotates around position X
in position y are going to be vectors
that the carrot is placed by the amount
of the vector on whichever axis away
from the base X so to explain that a
little more clearly if base X is in the
center position X in position Y are
going to be distances away from the base
on their respective axes and that's
what's going to determine how far from
the base the carrot is and we're going
to I'll show you how I'm using position
X in position Y in a second
just gonna move down here but I set a
random value up here and that basically
just makes all the carrots kind of
have a different path because otherwise
if I just set this up to be let's see
zero all the carrots would have the same
rotation pattern they'd all be
synchronized basically so if you look
now you can see very clearly that
they're all synchronized and that's kind
of a bad look so just go back to how was
before save and now you can see that
they all kind of move independently and
it's a lot less jarring to look at
because before it was almost like there
was a big just solid image of carrots
with the transparent background just
moving back and forth on the screen
that's not what we want to go for we
want to have independent movement we
want to have things looking like
everything is random so also speaking
about that up here the frame index if
you notice all the carrots on screen are
not sharing the same animation sequence
well they're sharing the same frames
obviously but if you look at too you can
see that they're animating at different
rates we just have to find two that are
going at offset values here these two
this one in this one they display the
opposite frame from one another so when
this one is on frame zero this one's on
frame one when this one was on frame one
this one's on frame 0 and that keeps
things looking fresh so if I come up
here and change this to just be 0 it's
gonna reduce the randomization and we're
just gonna have everything animating the
same exact way almost like it's updating
from the same exact animation object so
that's not we want either we want things
to randomly update their animation not
randomly but look like they have their
own unique animation even though they're
displaying the same frame so to do that
all I'm doing is I'm starting off the
animation at a randomized frame index
all right so now let's take a look at
what actually makes these things rotate
around the base X and base Y position
inside of the game carrot prototype
which is going to be the Pro
type our carrot class I have a function
called update position and that's that's
the only function for this class and
this is going to be called on every
frame of animation we're gonna talk
about this in the next part but all it
does is it updates the position X in
position Y value and sets the actual X
and actual Y value of the carrot object
which we're going to use to draw it to
the screen so excuse me position X in
position y what it does is it's just a
distance from the base so you can think
of it as a vector distance from the base
so Oh actually well that is true but
when I'm updating these it kind of
controls the speed of the animation so
if I were to make this 5 and this 9 and
save we're gonna see the carrots move a
lot more quickly so when I press refresh
up here now they're really moving like
those guys are jumping around quite a
bit there so that controls the speed at
which things move because on every frame
the animation I'm adding 0.5 or 0.9 to
these and that's going to make the thing
move a lot more quickly obviously so
let's get back to how things were
save come down here and look at how we
actually use these so math cosine and
math
sine are what's going to give us that
circular motion and we just plug in
position X in position Y into cosine and
sine and over here we have a multiplier
of 2 that's going to control the
distance that the carrots weighs on the
x-axis so if I come over here and
refresh to get things back to normal you
can see that it sways a little bit
further from side to side than it does
from up from top to bottom there so the
reason for that is because of this - if
I were to make this a 10 and save that
the carrots are gonna sway a lot more
from side to side than they do right now
so now you can see they're really
swaying from side to side but that looks
kind of ridiculous so we don't want that
but basically what's happening here is
we're just increasing we're
incrementing up position X in position y
matha cosine and matha
sine give us a nice rounded or circular
kind of effect there and then the
multiplier is just going to be how big
is that distance vector from the base
position
I guess it's actually a scalar because
it's only one single value but together
they make a vector so let's just put
that back to two so on every frame I'm
gonna call update position and this code
is gonna run and it's gonna make the
carrot move back and forth now if i
refresh everything's back to normal so
next I'm going to talk about how we
actually do the collision between the
carrot and the player to do the
collision detection between the player
object and the carrot object we need a
function that basically just does
closure detection between two squared
hip boxes so where that function is is
inside of game object so I'm gonna
scroll up to game object and we're gonna
take a look at the function that we use
to do that hit detection so here's the
game table jecht that prototype that's
just the prototype for a game the object
class and we have collide object and
what collide object does is it just
tests for square collision detection
between two rectangular objects so this
object is gonna collide with the
parameter object that I hand in so
basically I'll be able to hand in two
objects and determine whether or not
they're hit boxes are overlapping so
just wanted to show you this function
and now you'll kind of know where the
collision detection function is coming
from where I'm actually utilizing all
this is gonna be inside of game dot
world's update function so I'm gonna
come all the way down to the bottom all
the way down pass the player objects
pass the tile set object to world
objects inside of the about the setup
function but the update function so here
we are inside of the update function and
here we are going to call all of this
code on
reframe of our games animation and we
start up we we update the players
position we collide the player with the
game world to get the tile collision
going and then we're gonna start
colliding with carrots so we have a
carrots array that's gonna hold all of
our carrot objects that we created
inside of games setup or game that world
us set up rather we're gonna loop
through all of those carrot objects' so
just these guys here and we are going to
update the carrots position we're going
to animate the carrot and then we're
gonna say is the carrot colliding with
the player with the cloud object
function if that function returns true
we're going to splice that specific
carrot out of the carrots array and
we're going to just remove it completely
and we're going to add 1/2 carat count
and it's as simple as that
we're just gonna test for collision
between the player and the carrot if the
collision occurs we're gonna just remove
the carrot carrot object is totally gone
it will be garbage collected later on
assuming that I removed all references
to it I think I have so then what's
gonna happen is I'm going to increase
carrot count by 1 and carrot count is
what we're using to update this P
elements innerhtml right here so where
does that happen that happens inside of
the main J's file I come down to the
render function I have a P element it's
referenced with the P variable and I
just set its inner HTML to equal carrots
plus game world carrot count on every
frame and that's it so I hope you guys
learned something I hope you enjoyed the
video and I'll see you guys next time